This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
[inaudible]
mother fucking on master.
I got some,
a huge announcements.
Really?
Yeah.
For the tour.
First of all,
everybody who has come out so far,
we did two weekends so far.
San Francisco,
San Diego and they were bananas.
Amazing crowds.
I mean to call it the Paulien by tour.
Well not the next one.
That'll probably be,
I mean this year I'm announcing that I'm poly.
I think next year I'll announce it.
I'm also bisexual.
Um,
yeah.
But people have been just unbelievable.
So I just want to say thank you everybody that came out to those shows and let
you know.
Here is where we're adding,
we're doing a second show at the John Lyman Center for the Performing Arts in
new haven,
Connecticut,
Connecticut.
We are adding a second show in Portland,
May 1st at the Keller Auditorium Parkland.
We are adding a fourth show at the Moore Theater in Seattle,
Washington.
And here is the big one that I,
I can't believe this came together.
So the Chicago theater sold out two shows in April and we couldn't add any more
that weekend because of the other shows around it.
So I'm coming back to Chicago June 2nd to do a third show at the Chicago
theater.
Those are all on sale beginning Wednesday,
uh,
this Wednesday,
which is what January 16th,
10:00 AM local time and each of those markets,
uh,
thank you so much and a for the people asking about the other cities that will
first be announced on my email list.
If you sign up at my website,
[inaudible] dot com slash tour,
that email will go out and probably uh,
six weeks and that will announce the second half of the tour.
Your big ass stadium too.
My big ass theater tour.
I liked that.
So who you knew and those will all be,
that's going to be all the Canadian stuff,
the rest of the u s New York,
La,
all those markets,
that's going to be in about six weeks to see any of these cities names.
Well,
why don't you take over for me?
Kitty's yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Everybody who came out to the main room at the comedy last week.
We had
such a great time.
And for those of you who didn't come,
go fuck yourself now.
I'm just kidding.
I have another round of La shows May 31st you can see me,
uh,
May 31st through June 1st I just added that weekend and Sperm Bank of California
at Flip Paris comedy club.
And uh,
also Denver.
I'm coming two weeks,
January 31st to February 2nd Denver.
Wow.
How do you say Denver again?
He always used to say,
mom,
birth mom for
the,
come on.
You works there.
Tickets are really moving quick.
So get them now.
February 23rd west Salaam springs.
I'm doing that.
Oklahoma Cherokee casino.
February 28th through March 2nd Madison,
Wisconsin.
The con club on state.
Yeah.
April four,
three six mini apple tits.
Fantastic city.
Amazing.
Yes.
The acne comedy club.
And then May 10th and 11th is going to be good.
Tempe.
Uh,
and we,
we got to say it like a real Arizona,
Tempe,
Arizona.
The Tempe Improv May 31st through June 2nd,
like I mentioned for repairs here in sperm bank.
And then June 20th to 22nd Washington Dick come at the Dick.
Come improv tickets at.
People really want to hear that.
They do.
They love it.
Okay.
I'll tell you,
cause when I tweeted out and write the correct way,
I get chastised.
Claire Fans.
Okay.
Christina p online for all those ticket links.
God bless you.
Uh,
before I forget,
I don't want to forget.
Um,
the store has been a blown up.
Thank you so much.
All you,
for all you guys,
uh,
supporting the sto.
Um,
there are of course the good morning Julia shirts and full throttle.
There's also good morning Julia mugs and good morning Julia socks.
Um,
in addition to that,
we have a restock.
Some of the all time classics that people love,
such as,
uh,
just glass and Piss on me,
beat me hikes,
bikes.
Um,
there's a few other ones and they'd been restocked.
So thank you very much.
Those are@merchantmethod.com slash Thomas cigarettes.
Also,
I like to repost a lot of your videos on the gram.
I'm at the Christine and P if you want to see stuff that we don't cover on this
show.
That's true.
The Christina,
all your Sigora Tom,
that's a great time because of British boys.
Tom Cigarette.
He's a nice kid though.
A mummy.
Wow.
And there it is.
Jean,
what's going to happen?
We got our business out of the way.
It's going to be show time.
Are you ready to get into this?
Are you ready to do this show?
I'm a little nervous because you've already told me that you're fond of one of
the gentlemen.
Oh,
this isn't that good to know.
This is really good,
but yes,
there's a lot of good stuff today.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Let's get this party started.
Sure.
Bible.
But I wanted to make this video.
I want to confess drawn to domestic violence and the seriousness of it.
I've been with my wife for 19 years.
I believe in beating women.
I believe him.
I have beat my wife in the past several times and I'm serious.
I'm very serious.
Oh,
hi Auntie.
Don't bring anyone loving to them.
Well,
welcome.
Welcome to your mom's house
and
Christina.
Hmm.
What do you think you see a trend forming in our clip choices?
What kind of guy?
What kind of guy would you describe him as?
Just cool guys.
Guys who love women.
Yeah.
Pro Ladies.
This is,
he's so sincere.
Yeah,
he is.
I actually think he's a pretty nice guy.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
It's confusing cause he does come off as a really swell guy and then he dropped
that bomb and he just,
he just has a different angle,
you know?
I don't understand why everyone was a fucking stupid idiot.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
So really descended into a cool lane,
but you know what's,
what's,
what is scarier?
The guy who's yelling stuff like that guy.
Yeah.
Or a cool,
calm and collected guy who was like,
you've got a beat.
A woman I have.
Right,
right,
right.
I see your point.
Which one's more serial?
Serial killery.
I mean definitely the cool,
calm guy they call this is more terrifying because he didn't pass for a regular
human.
I mean he's got,
let's see what else.
I think he's got some other things to say.
Sitting in my backyard.
I'm reading my Bible,
but I want it to make this video.
I want to confess regarding domestic violence of the seriousness of it.
I've been with my wife for 19 years,
I believe in beating women.
Yeah.
I believe in,
I have beat my wife for the past several times and I'm serious.
I'm very serious.
Um,
I believe there comes a time when you have to just beat her,
especially when she hits you and cusses you out and get out of place.
This is how we had in the past.
We used to drink and club back in the day when we wasn't,
so we may get into a physical altercation.
Right.
When she hit me,
she was about one 35 then that was about two 50.
I would just sit there and crack up at it
and laugh and just said,
what are you doing?
Well,
women are not scared of us because they are,
they were came from us.
They're not scared of us.
So they five,
three woman was challenges six,
seven,
a man because of the man that's in her.
But,
um,
the way I beat her,
I literally would just ignore her.
The fuck no her,
she'll jump on my back.
I just laugh.
Okay.
Wow.
It sounds like these two are a volatile couple to begin with.
Yeah.
And he's all,
I mean he's,
he's going over the Bible right now.
It's in,
it is in the Bible.
He doesn't usually,
what prompts me,
it gets me in the mood,
you know,
it was,
um,
to me,
whenever I go,
like I'm going to read the Bible,
I'll think about when I beat women to write,
he'd,
they do have all kinds of crazy shit like that in the Bible though.
The Bible does have wild shit.
Yeah.
So this guy is just reading.
He's just doing what he's told.
Yeah.
He's doing what he's told.
Um,
how much does he weigh?
He said two 50 and she was one one 35.
Yeah.
That's not a fair fight.
But now he said,
he said like,
oh,
what I do is I will laugh at her and I'll ignore her and that's how I beat her.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
I think he was trying to make a point.
Like you can beat someone emotionally.
Yeah.
You can emotionally abuse somebody in when,
which is fun too,
which is really all key ingredients to a great marriage.
Awesome.
What are you getting out of punching a woman in the face?
Right.
It's more,
it's more of a victory when you beat her the right way.
God still wants to come after you hard and once a fight too.
This is what you do.
Get method.
I'm talking to men and women.
If you're in the heat of battle,
if you want to beat her,
both of you just get Mecca because if you get naked Mecca,
you can't stay mad that long.
Looking at your wife and man's beauty,
there's a way to beat your wife.
And I'm not talking about physically,
I'm talking about psychologically,
uh,
a how often and be honest.
Yeah.
Do you want to hit me?
Not Often.
No.
Come on.
There are times I really make you mad.
No.
Nine when you really don't like me.
Uh,
never.
No,
no.
Women are stupid.
Yeah.
Thanks for introducing that.
Mean that whole thing.
Because now,
uh,
in my comments and all my Twitter and stuff,
it'll be like a great show.
Christine,
you dumb bitch come in to see in Denver you stupid cotton like,
oh.
Oh Lisa,
it's so hard to meet a girl just to fucking fuck bro.
Yeah.
Christine,
you stupid bitch.
Yeah.
That's a fun new lane.
Okay.
A lot of women out there fully fucking full of shit and it's stupid.
Yeah.
Says Einstein.
Do you like that this guy's done his research?
I think that pastor actually has good intentions,
but he,
uh,
he uses
phrases like there's a way to beat your woman.
Right?
So he meant to say like,
there's a way to deal with anger.
Correct.
Don't be physical,
like keep composed and maybe,
you know,
walk away.
But he said there's a way to beat your woman.
Yeah.
Right.
I see you're saying he's saying beat her as in when the argument still sounds
really aggressive,
but he still wants to hurt her,
which is nice.
Which is like the point and your spouse want her to emotionally fall apart.
And that's how you it.
Because that's really the key to a good marriage is when you want to destroy
that other person.
Right.
Of course you're fighting or just
shaming them.
And that's how we do.
Yes.
That's how you and I am staying for advice.
You know,
you don't like it.
Delete me.
Bang.
I don't give a fuck.
There you go.
That my boyfriend like your boyfriend Ted.
Cause you've been getting a lot of those.
Oh my God.
It's just uh,
it's,
it's fun.
It is.
Hey Hitler,
that's a neat one.
Obviously always,
always.
And now being called the dumb bitch is really special.
Hitler,
when you walk on stage,
it's still a really cool thing to hear.
There's a Hitler.
I'm like,
cool,
because there's still people that don't know.
Of course you're the comedy store to Tuesday night packed main room.
Yeah.
And then somebody just as the applause dies goes,
Hey Hitler,
dude,
what are you doing?
Well now I'm going to get Christine,
you dumb bitch.
I Dunno.
Make me dinner.
You stupid bitch.
We have to get into it.
Yeah.
Look,
we have to get into it.
First of all.
Um,
I love it here and I just wanted to say that,
but I wanted to point something out.
It's not just that I love it here and you love it here.
The fans love it here.
I have never seen anything like this.
We literally got 100% positive feedback on the new set.
That was something that I didn't expect.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm glad that everybody feels like it's a home run.
Yup.
And that everybody wants
everything to stay the same and people love change.
If it's one thing we know about humans as they adapt really well to new things.
Yes.
I'm just so surprised to how much love we been getting on the set.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
People really,
you know,
yeah.
They,
they,
they're just thrilled with what we've done.
So I'm happy that they're happy and,
um,
I want to point out a couple things though.
One thing,
uh,
as somebody pointed out was that,
they thought I didn't control the,
the sound anymore.
That's false.
Got that wrong.
I have a scooter to my right that you might not be able to see.
Yeah.
But I still play all the sound drops,
uh,
myself,
they're all right here.
So yeah.
Secondly,
yeah,
there are some things that have changed and,
um,
that's just the way it goes.
You know,
one of the,
uh,
one of the things that happened was that people were sending in comments and I
asked our great production staff here to pool with some of the,
um,
comments about the new set.
Great.
I'd love to hear like,
you know,
I feel good because it just reinforces that we've made good decisions and that
the audience is on our side.
Oh,
it feels good to read.
Well,
here's some of the ones you want to hear.
Some of them love to hear it.
All right.
My reaction to this new studio is the same as the decapitated German shepherds
reaction.
Okay.
Positive.
Yeah,
he smiles.
go ahead.
This set is somewhat both a Mcdonald's and a 1980s finished basement.
Yeah.
It looks like a Chinese Communist Party boardroom.
[inaudible] studio looks like a court room.
A Mcdonald's.
That's good.
Okay.
The new studio looks like a library that sells VHS tapes.
I think you mean lie berry?
Definitely a green screen behind Tom.
This step might actually be a joke.
I hope it is.
I also got a lot of green screen messages.
Why are you in front of a green screen?
Why is that?
They don't believe the dog is real,
but I dunno.
I Dunno.
I think it was like the lack of shadows or something.
It's not a green screen,
but here.
All right,
let's,
let's just go straight down.
Tell,
tell people clean what happened.
Oh yeah.
So we're going to come over here.
We're going to build this set.
And um,
you know,
all of our agents and stuff know about it.
So I get this call a few months ago and one of my agents goes,
hey,
how do you feel about working with Mcdonald's?
And I said like,
I don't feel one way or the other about it.
Honestly,
I love Mcdonald's pride.
I mean,
it's great,
but I mean,
at the time I'm like,
what do you mean?
He's like,
well,
you know,
someone over there,
they,
they liked the show there fans,
um,
would you consider having them,
uh,
how help decorate the new set and they'll give you $100,000.
And I said,
dude,
like I have integrity,
right?
I'm not just going to let Mcdonald's through $100,000 at me and just go like,
oh,
now they,
they pick the color scheme.
You know,
he's like,
fair enough.
I,
you know,
that's fair.
And I figured that's that.
And also keep in mind,
Mcdonald's has discovered that the way to really advertise and reach people is
to do it more embedded.
Like remember we covered that thing,
that story where the Asian kid took a picture of he and his friends and he put
it in the Mcdonald's corporate kind of realize the way to sell now to the
millennials is to make it more embedded and more organic.
So that was,
that was the pitch to part of the intention that they had.
Well,
he calls me back a week later,
unprompted.
We haven't any comedy or conversations about it.
He said,
hey,
Mcdonald's wants to know,
I thought we,
I thought we already talked about this.
You said a,
they'll give you $250,000.
And I go,
dude,
I'm not like,
I'm not doing that,
you know?
Right.
So I don't hear from him for,
uh,
this time,
like,
I dunno,
three or four weeks more and this side and now like the,
the layout has is picked and there's already a design coming.
He calls me up and he goes,
hey,
I know this sounds crazy,
but you know,
Mcdonald's and I go again with the Mcdonald's.
He goes,
how does two point $3 million sound?
Okay.
Yeah.
And what do they want to do?
He's like,
they want to design the set and then you guys get like free Mcdonald's all the
time.
And I go,
do they dictate like,
uh,
you know,
are they going to pick out what we can talk about and stuff?
And he's like,
no,
he's like,
go hardcore.
You know,
just let Mcdonald's have a little fucking stay.
Yeah.
And I'm a huge fan of their products already.
This is kind of a no brainer.
Easy.
I tell you,
I can't remember the last time I had a filet of fish,
but it's fantastic if you had this and drinks are amazing.
Amazing.
The coke is always so sweet and bubbly.
It's just an the nuggets.
I love the nuggets.
Which one's your favorite?
But yeah,
I really like keep it simple.
Cheeseburgers,
fries,
chicken nuggets.
Yeah.
Especially if you're drunk.
They asked us not to say that,
but
if you're drunk it's even better.
Oh fuck yeah.
We also picked up our happy meals on the way in banks,
Mcdonald's,
Hank,
you,
Mcdonald's.
The neatest part is that,
I mean we're trying to get them to Redo this policy,
but they did ask as the happy meal for a boy or a girl.
Yeah.
What's up with that?
I want you to pick your own pronouns.
We're going to have to educate them on the non binary stuff.
But other than that,
what toy did you get?
And your happy meal.
Oh,
let's see.
What do I did?
I guess I got the boys one.
This is a truck.
I got a bread truck.
No,
it's gay.
Oh,
I got a cat with a girl.
what did they put fruit in here now?
Oh No.
Oh boy.
Oh,
I like these fries though.
It's delicious.
Thank you.
Mcdonald's.
You know,
so many people message me about Mcdonald's.
Um,
some variants,
halting ways.
One in such a way that I didn't even feel comfortable repeating it.
So I had it recorded.
This is what somebody messaged me about art.
You got to Mcdonald's nigger.
Huh?
I Dunno.
What's tone that is,
is that complimentary?
Oh,
you're saying that we got that as a,
as a common comment.
And then you had somebody maybe read it out loud.
Out Loud.
Yeah.
Can we hear it again?
Well that was,
you got to Mcdonald's nigger.
That's what he's like.
He's a little dismayed by it or something.
Sure.
You got a Mcdonald's liquor and that celebrate,
right?
You did this good for you.
So the answer is yeah,
yeah,
it did.
And a loving.
So
there's a lot to celebrate and I hope that everybody's,
uh,
as happy as we are with um,
the corporate sponsorship.
We have the Burgers,
we have filet of fish,
many,
many French fries,
all that we want.
Oh good.
It's so good.
I know there really is a big map that's,
it's been a long time,
but now I feel like it's going to be a regular part of my diet with a,
their involvement.
So,
well you can't make it Paleo if you just don't need the bunk.
Let me just tell some other address.
One other thing about the new setup here.
So people were really flipping out about,
you know,
how everything's working.
Just give it a second man.
Things will change.
You know,
like you just got to get some people flipped out.
It's like dude,
we're trying things out.
Like today for instance,
you know,
we have tech things going on today.
If you're watching the show,
you won't see us picture in picture can we have some type of glitch?
So you're going to see the videos full frame.
I Dunno,
you might end up liking that.
Maybe we'll end up doing it.
I who knows.
Well,
another difference you might notice is that the set lighting is darker.
It's darker.
Mcdonald's gave us the,
okay.
Yeah.
We had to ask them.
We said we turned down the lights and they were like,
yeah,
okay.
We did feel it was a little bright for steak house.
And I was like,
you have to get back any money.
And they were like,
no,
but you know,
don't,
don't make it be darker.
No.
When people don't know that you're still at our restaurant.
So.
Right.
Well the neat thing about Mcdonald's is a sponsor is that they don't censor us.
They don't,
they let us do what you want,
what they want.
And like,
you know,
we might even do some things where like,
well,
we'll take some of you guys out to Mcdonald's,
you know.
Well that's cool.
Yeah.
It could be like a cool,
maybe like we'll do a,
a road alive,
your mom's house and then we'll take everyone and McDonald's awesome.
Or we'll have it catered.
You know,
that's the kind of life we live here.
Yeah.
Fucking do so
well.
Anyway.
That's what happened.
And that's what happened.
Speaking of awesome sponsors.
Yeah.
Um,
the wonderful people at Saatva,
if you listened last week,
um,
were kind enough to allow us to do a type of contest gene and the contest is
that we can,
um,
we put out a call to the listeners and we asked you guys to tell us why you
deserved a free Saatva mattress.
They're letting us give away a couple of them.
We're going to do a luxury mattress and illumine leaf memory foam mattress.
And you have to tell us why you bombarded the email account with so many
submissions.
These guys
had to filter through,
I don't know,
more than a hundred or 200 you said.
And um,
yeah,
a lot.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
these are your selects of some of the best ones.
Yeah,
we narrowed it down.
Um,
there was hundreds that got submitted and me and Josh went through them and
picked our favorites.
Okay.
Um,
I guess we can,
should we just watch them in succession?
Let them rip?
Yeah,
we picked our top eight.
Okay.
We think it's a good representative of everyone.
We stop after each one.
Sure.
Okay.
All right.
Let's,
let's,
let's go.
Ready Gene?
Good Morning Sandra.
It's me.
Trains.
Just wanted to say hi.
What's your a great day and telling you that you're giving away a free mattress
to a mommy.
Need this one of the greatest opportunity to do so.
My life,
since I finished putting myself through college,
I had to move out of state for work and haven't been able to afford furniture.
Should have been sleeping on the floor before.
Crown Molding.
Please help me erase that from my memory of this mattress.
Like it's never been loved before.
I could really see my cell phone asleep on you,
so let's make it happen.
Ciao baby.
Very cool.
Well done.
And also tugged at the heartstrings a little bit.
Definitely expresses a clear need here for a match.
He does.
Trey have sleeping like I did on a dog bed.
No.
You at least had a mattress portray.
Yeah.
So far so good.
I mean,
I would say the tray
go morning.
Saatva me,
Joe here about you extend the way mattresses the other day.
I couldn't stop thinking about you.
As you can see my mattress,
he,
it's old and may time I have a guest over,
they say that they're scared or uncomfortable.
They just want to go back home to the old mattress.
So,
uh,
I hope this message doesn't scare you,
but I promise if you send me another mattress,
I won't ever go back to my old mattress.
Somebody even know who my ex masters was,
but that's all you're getting for now.
Saatva shall baby.
Wow.
For those of you just listening to the show,
he had a woman tied to his existing mattress in the background,
had ankles,
wrists and a,
a bag or something over her head.
So it was terrifying and very well,
uh,
very creative.
Very well orchestrated.
I will say for this gentleman,
yes.
What I do like is his shirtlessness.
He really got some points there.
Yeah,
that was,
yeah.
Steve and Sarah.
Sure.
Big points.
We're going shirtless.
And that's one of the your mom's house hallmark.
Yeah.
Have a good video.
Shirtlessness poor lighting homies.
Oh,
I think I should get the mattress because I have never had a new mattress.
I'm currently sleeping on the one my grandmother.
Yeah,
winner,
winner chicken dinner.
I think they found that was pretty great.
Yup.
I like that.
What's
the deal man?
Broke college student.
He skipped fucked a lot.
Man.
Black guys has on me when I'm sleeping on an inflatable mattress.
Oh,
so please
stop.
Uh,
open up your heart and your arms to me.
Give me a real mattress.
The home here now waiting for delivery.
I love it.
He gets my vote for sure.
For sure.
She's getting one like,
you know what I like is that she chose reason and logic.
That was a,
a reasonable argument.
Is this person a pre law?
She knows her audience.
Even though a real handy guy,
cause I'm looking
at a lease in a key and even bring your friends,
man,
I,
here's the deal man,
but I can't do this on this piece of crap,
so I need your help.
Mommy's helped me get a new mask,
hot white come dump and I need
wow.
Wow.
I mean,
look,
she's got the lighting down,
she's got different themes from your mom's house.
She's got the acting chops.
Yup.
Wow.
She nailed it to fuck.
That's so,
and Christine,
I think I should get the mattress because I don't have a fucking mattress.
Oh,
sweet.
And to the point.
Very direct.
Ooh.
[inaudible]
strokes.
Very creative.
Wow.
Very talented people out there.
30 seconds is not a lot of time.
I know to be funny and informative.
So was good.
We kept it to that though.
For sure.
Mommy,
mommy,
Christina coming at you from your favorite camera angle.
Some my mattress situation.
The springs are gone.
Full mattress.
So I have to lay a towel on top.
That one was oh my life.
God.
I mean,
how are we supposed to choose?
I don't know man.
I Dunno.
That was really good though.
No.
And again,
like when the,
when he shows you the,
uh,
horrific mattress,
you're going to want to just give you a,
but then there are people that don't even have a mattress.
And then there are people's grandmas died on their mattresses.
And then there are girls,
I wanna fuck black guys on their match.
Right.
Do you think that all right.
So,
um,
I can't decide right now.
Are we supposed to decide right now?
Uh,
we probably should.
Yeah.
I'm like,
who's your favorite?
Which ones can we go to the most?
I like the girl who mashed together the different videos and at the end finished
in the dark as the tryout guy.
I mean I have stability for the last guy and the grandma one,
those three,
I feel like tugged at my heart,
my heart strings.
I liked those as well.
I was going to vote for the last guy and then the first girl with the bike in
her living room with the air mattress.
Oh,
smash.
You know,
she's trying to get,
get with the black dudes.
So you're saying we should get a black guy and then the girl who wants a
mattress to fuck the black guys on.
Okay.
Can you might not ruin,
oh,
sorry.
Earning at that had died that Jesus,
God,
I'm loving it.
So,
um,
here's what I'm going to,
I dunno.
Um,
yeah,
I vote for.
So who do you vote for?
Yeah,
I mean,
I personally,
I vote,
I vote for Ray.
The last guy.
I mean,
he seems like he's most in need of a mattress.
He's got a like a metal spring poking him in the back and he's got to lit towel
down for,
Gosh,
do we all agree that there's one given that level of suffering?
Yeah.
And sometimes sleeping on the floors better than sleeping on a mat on that kind
of,
okay.
So there's one,
oh my God.
Okay,
go ahead.
What about,
what's your,
what's your next favorite one?
A next favorite one?
I'd probably say the girl that runs through all the different why made stuff?
Yeah,
that's the girl that I liked.
That one at the end.
Okay.
That guy,
uh,
that has the girl tied up in the bed.
That's my points for that.
There's points for that.
True.
Well,
it sounds like you both voted for that girl then,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
There it is.
There's two people they want.
Hey,
those are our winners.
Congratulations.
Uh,
for the two people is the girl and a and the guy with the metal spring.
Pocono.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
[inaudible]
congratulations guys.
Yeah.
Enjoy your new site for mattress.
We've been sleeping on ours for a long time and thank you for participating.
Um,
in that,
that fun giveaway.
How was fun?
It was Tommy.
Yeah.
You had some explosive Brown's today.
Oh,
it was really bad.
I don't know what happened to me,
but I have a theory all morning long for bad and I'm upset because we couldn't
come here fast enough.
And you couldn't use a fart mic.
Oh,
it's empty.
There's nothing in the chamber.
Yeah,
I mean,
I got to say,
if I had had what I had,
um,
last week or like this morning last week,
it would've been so epic.
Right.
I was actually,
I will say,
and I give you full credit.
Okay.
I'm not trying to share the credit.
I give you full credit.
A lot of people were celebrating as they were knocking the studio design.
Sure.
They were saying,
well,
the one saving grace is that Fart,
Mike.
Right.
Which is your credit.
Um,
I honestly,
if I could go back,
I wouldn't have even farted in it the first time because it was such a minuscule
fart.
It was so insignificant and to me the Fart Mike should be reserved for huge
impact.
Far It's only,
wait,
what are you telling me?
You're telling me that you're a fart supremacist and you only want the biggest
farts.
Yes.
That fart last week was so like,
it was like Tom,
all farts matter.
No,
I don't think so.
I'm not going to grab this thing every time I have to farm.
You've got to do it.
That's your obligation to the listeners.
That's what the Fart Mike is for.
When you heard what I did in the at home today,
in the morning when that was like,
that was amazing.
That's amazing.
That's something that I would share it,
but what kind of attitude is this that that not all the farts are going to make
it to Fart,
Mike.
Some are good and some are better.
That's just how life is.
You can't bat,
you can't bat a perfect score.
Whatever they say in baseball.
Right.
I'm so empty right now.
There's nothing left in me.
Why don't you eat some more McDonald's?
Oh,
we'll talk to the sponsor of weights.
A number.
You're being serious here that you're going to be kind of lazy about the FARC.
Mike is what I'm hearing.
I'm going to be selective.
I wouldn't say it's lazy at all.
I'm going to say I'm going to grab that FARC,
Mike,
when I feel like,
Ooh,
this is,
this is something that I'm not just going to do it for.
Like I broke the mold here,
I Chris,
but it was with a,
it was a lame fart.
Do you feel that people judge the Fart?
That it wasn't big enough?
I know that I'm more critical of myself than other people are.
I'm a perfectionist.
I want it to be a certain level.
Right?
So yeah,
I'm sure people out there were like,
what?
What is that?
That wasn't even a fart.
That's what you heard.
That's what I heard.
You know?
I think,
I think you should bring this up in therapy because I think you're just hearing
your own negative talk.
That's negative self talk.
That's true.
I think that part was great.
No,
you need to give yourself more credit for your work as a r t I don't think so.
You need to give yourself some credit.
That's very nice to you.
But I don't feel that way.
Okay.
Sorry.
I can only you know,
you,
you hear what you want to hear.
Yeah,
just didn't,
I don't,
I didn't feel like it today.
Well then just for the audience listening,
I'm going to get continued to give you all my farts.
All I have and you decide which ones you like.
Yeah.
That's just
on a side note.
I just wanted to give you a surprise.
Um,
there's something,
I've been working on a with an a dog here.
What for a minute.
Um,
okay.
Well I'm a dog.
We know we've been a discussion about who drinks the most water.
Oh,
for fucks.
And we just put a little compilation.
How many episodes is this
dot.
So this is a span of the last four episodes and something that I've been doing
for the last six months is whenever someone's taking a clear sip of water,
I cut to them for the duration of the sip.
So I've compiled a little bit of stuff to show you guys a,
Christina's got a lot of footage of
the last episode.
Go ahead.
Roll it.
Let's see it.
Oh really?
Last week,
one of my favorite moments when we had done a gun was when you and I just looked
at each other.
Yeah.
Good.
Now hands,
Garry.
Garry Oak is first baby.
That doesn't really say that,
but I'll tell you this.
And I thought this the other day at cleaned my room.
What's up?
Like so and like I have never,
it's the best thing I've ever heard it so long.
So she's like,
when he was feeding people,
alright,
it's very long.
We're maybe halfway.
Oh my God.
You're going to you that for the audience I was to.
But you know what would made a judgement call?
Uh,
let's,
uh,
take a look at Thompson.
Oh for fuck sake.
Alright,
here's Tom.
Well,
I can tell you
something that will probably blow your mind.
And that is that I was actually told to dial back my way.
Yeah,
true.
Stop it.
It's true.
What are you going to stop with the excuses?
It's not an excuse.
It's very true.
You're such a liar face.
Yeah.
That was over at,
uh,
that diagnostics like blood and they were like,
you need,
you're hydrating too much.
Uh Huh.
So what I've been doing is I just pick up a little window of time window
hydrate.
You're such a liar.
Not,
I can't believe.
Now you're spitting this,
that it's a medical necessity for you to drink less water.
There's no doctor's going to tell you to drink a last one.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
there are good ones.
Well,
oh my God,
I can't believe you're such a liar.
Well,
are you finally going to admit that I'm the true water champ now the evidence?
No,
I'm not.
I mean the evidence was there,
that video,
we had to stop watching it.
It was a minute long of montage of just me drinking
it.
Look
what you did in that video while sure.
It looks,
it looks like it's impressive.
If you're talking about a camera rolling all day,
I would be like in an ocean.
Okay.
You're doing it.
You're like,
oh,
there's a camera on.
Unbelievable.
Hold on.
Believable.
We'll show.
Unbelievable.
Unbelievable is right.
I can't believe Yana will.
I'll,
uh,
the audience to decide.
You guys,
you decide,
I mean,
you've been watching me drink and hydrate and he doesn't,
it's clear that I'm the champion.
Thank you.
How's that nugget?
What's your favorite dipping sauce?
I like the barbecue.
I want to thank Steve Nice and my golf for setting it up today.
Yeah,
it's good.
I like the MC rib.
It's a seasonal item.
Did you know that it's not there all year?
Did you know that there's a,
there's pickles on the [inaudible] to,
yeah,
of course.
Some people didn't know that.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
Great.
American food.
MMM.
This is rare,
but I drink so much water that that's take a pee break.
Oh,
stop it.
let's do a quick pee break and we'll be right back.
Oh Man,
those are good pee break.
I know.
I just ain't that big Mac.
I feel so sick now,
dude.
Oh,
I feel nourished.
Amy Sponsor crying out loud.
Women are stupid.
Uh,
yeah.
Anyways,
I feel so nourished and I feel healthy and happy now that I ate some Mcdonald's.
Um,
you know,
pause for another bathroom break.
We,
um,
we went like a month ago to a Laker game,
which was a thrill.
I've always loved sports.
I always felt like you were kind of on the edge with it.
Like we were like,
well take it or leave it or whatever.
Not really care.
But you had,
um,
the best time I did.
I really enjoyed it.
You really,
really loved,
uh,
going to the game.
But I want us to go back to Morgan.
I Dunno what you loved about it.
I had a different ideas,
but um,
you,
you mentioned that you were having a great time.
It got me excited to want to go to more basketball games and there's this,
um,
young lady here who is also a fan of basketball.
You might relate to her in a lot of ways.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
My favorite basketball team is whatever NBA player.
I'm fucking,
I love watching basketball.
It's just way more interesting when there's someone on the team like that I'm
linked to,
but I don't have a favorite one.
Just players
I think was real too.
I believe it.
She's really cute.
She's cute.
NBA s l u t t is,
and look at it.
What sheet and our pasta,
making videos about it too,
in a way.
You know what this really is.
It's like this video is like a bat signal.
Yeah.
Gay players.
Yes.
So she talks about it in a general sense,
but then if you're a player,
you're like,
Hey,
what's up?
What are you like,
Hey,
what's up?
I'm going to be in.
You got to meet Thursday.
Yeah.
Though there's a,
there's definitely,
I mean,
she knows,
she knows what she's doing to,
I believe it.
Well,
I believe,
I think you're right.
It's kind of like that chick that called herself superhead.
Yeah,
I remember.
And she's like,
I didn't the best head.
And then before,
you know,
there's a line of guys around the block.
Oh yeah,
right,
Tom?
Oh yeah.
Tom Goes,
oh yeah,
oh boy.
At school that hadn't takes like that.
Yeah.
Good
for her.
I will say,
you know,
in my youth I was so stupid because I was like,
I would just give it out,
give it out,
but for a free hot dog or whatever,
yeah.
At least she's getting her money.
You think she's getting her money?
She's eating good pasta.
That's the,
I don't know.
I'm hoping that she's getting something or for it or just getting like handbags
and stuff,
you know?
Sure.
No,
me like I was like,
I love people I have.
Yeah,
I bet.
yeah,
yeah.
I believe in love and stuff like that.
First thing often doubt is the doubt because I love sucking Dick,
but
here's the thing,
there's a lot of guys that have been with that.
I never sucked your day or if we were intimate,
it wasn't a focal point,
so I don't know.
Now that's one of your favorite things is when girls talking about how they law.
Yeah.
I always think that's a little fishy when a girl leaves with that,
like I just love index.
I also believe that she's good at it cause she puts it out there.
Yeah.
But that's like the same guy who wears a thumb ring and he's like,
I'm a feminist.
It's the same.
It's the same bait of like,
look how cool I am.
I do the thing every,
everybody wants me to do of the opposite sex.
But do you feel like all you gotta do is basically,
I don't know,
put it out there.
Like if you say it then,
then people will believe it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
You're just defining yourself.
Like I'm the world's greatest comedian.
You keep saying that long enough and the right people believe you.
You know what's interesting sidebar,
um,
is that this new craze with the,
the eyelashes,
have you noticed this?
Yeah.
The girls have just outrageously large eyelashes.
They're big and fake and they,
it,
they look so matted together.
It doesn't look good.
Anything that seems like an extreme starts to look cartoonish.
Yeah.
You,
no,
you look like a cartoon.
I like her message though.
It's sort of the same message,
uh,
that,
um,
dairy.
You remember how you got that?
Our friend last week.
That guys good.
Thank you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No thanks.
I don't want to hear,
I don't want to visit it again.
It's great.
All done.
Oh,
Yo.
Beautiful women.
No.
Yeah,
he's the guy,
right?
No thanks.
He's,
he's so good at,
okay.
All right.
I don't know.
Do you think she's a good SLU ut?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You've always said that,
that you can tell who's a slot and who's not.
Right.
But I feel like your criteria is kind of our,
I would have pegged her.
I would've,
I would've known.
How do you know she's a slot?
Okay.
Let's just say like she,
you don't hear her talking about second decks and stuff.
Yeah.
Tell me what the giveaway is.
I mean,
look,
it's a combination of things.
It's the way that it's definitely the way,
you know,
they look the way they look at you.
You know,
the eye contact,
the way someone's stressed that hair,
eye contacts.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
I'm looking at you right now.
Like what?
What do you mean it's a special icon?
There's a slut.
I energy.
Yeah,
I slept I energy.
Can you show me your sled?
I energy
but I energy.
Hold on.
You can't tell by looking at this whole that she's a hoe?
No,
because when the video started I was like,
Oh,
who's this nice.
You're nice young lady.
She say anything else like this that,
uh,
makes us believe that she's,
I'm just honest.
I don't fear anyone or anything,
so I never find it necessary to lie.
You asked me,
did you come babe?
Nope.
Try again next time.
Okay,
last question.
Two bits of advice.
I allow myself to feel if I don't allow myself to feel the emotions get trapped,
therefore I'm suppressing and then when I suppressed,
I become,
when you allow yourself to feel it goes.
Number two was,
I don't judge myself.
I allow myself however much time I need to take it off for it.
And actually,
can I tell you something?
You had real insight there.
Sure.
She really did.
She's been in therapy for 10 years too.
Yeah.
I'm putting it out there so much.
Oh,
that's what it is,
you think because so many guys have run a train on her.
So much calm.
Yeah.
Clippers Christ.
Yeah,
for sure.
Is she a cheerleader?
She could have been because I always think those,
uh,
like when we saw the lake or is I'm like,
oh,
I wonder if all those true leaders are banging all the players.
They are right.
I think back in the day,
I don't think anymore.
I don't think anymore because there's no money in cheerleading.
No.
Thank you.
So,
so this is what I've been so excited.
Thank you.
By the way.
I want to say a couple of things about that girl.
I think she's actually highly intelligent.
Yeah.
I think she's bright.
She had also had a hoe nails.
There's another giveaway.
Nails were hoe ish.
She had the car.
I didn't see it in the first thing,
but the,
the half top thing,
that's a slight lean.
You're leaning into your home.
Um,
and yeah,
I think she's bright,
but she's putting it out there and that's fine.
Hold on.
I'm happy for her.
Can we bring up now?
I like her.
Thank you.
You're married.
Two children.
Two dogs show to get fair.
Do you think you can identify gimme some other slut markers?
Oh,
I mean leggings,
um,
shoes,
certain shoes or giveaways or the shoes and the leggings.
There's just,
there's certain,
there's certain like there's certain heels that are for Ho oh absolutely.
Certain boots that uggs or slept shoes sometimes just depends.
Let's see who's this hole right here?
So funny.
You're always saying that to me.
Cause if I see like her whole gear,
it,
this isn't the whole outfit.
The,
this is where like the,
so she's not a slut.
Is this girl a slut?
She fucks.
I mean,
I wouldn't call her a slut,
but I mean it's not like it's impossible to fuck her.
She's,
but she's not as,
she's easier,
but she's
not a full slide.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
cause I wear that helmet.
That girl is that girl slept?
No,
no,
we talked about it.
Let me,
she goes a sculpting class with that pattern on there and,
okay.
Okay.
That's me by the way.
How about that lady?
I mean,
she fucks,
you could tell,
you know,
it's like she,
she definitely fucks hard now.
I wear leggings with Ugg boots and every time I do at the house,
you're like,
like such a slut.
Mm.
Um,
yeah.
I mean that's j Lo,
is she a slut?
No,
I mean that's like,
you know,
in the outfit,
again,
it's,
it's the,
the,
Ugh,
it can be an accessory of hotem or it can be like a,
obviously something that provides comfort and me here,
she's obviously on set.
She's probably wearing heels or something during the scene.
And that's just downtime.
I mean,
I get it.
I don't think that that in this situation defines her as a whole.
But I mean there's definitely la hoes at the Wareham,
those ugg boots though.
They're made with dog fur on the inside.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
They stink to high heaven.
Oh,
hugs.
Oh my God,
they're called that because they stink there.
Is it dog for,
for real kind of furs in there.
It's not Doug for a,
so here's the,
okay,
this is what I've been so excited.
No thanks.
You know,
no pulled on.
You know how,
you know how you had to get my shrink dial?
Any like has featured some of the coolest guys.
I have botox can't scowl,
but I want to scour through the botox.
You know how some of the coolest guys ever have appeared on this show?
Well,
yeah,
there's something cool there is they they,
there's no end to how many cool guys are out there.
That's it.
Yeah.
Yeah
guys.
Shit again and I'm here to do a little video.
No,
you can use this but by greening toy that I bought this new one and I thought
I'd try that again.
And then I also wanted to try this.
Step one did fuck sleep that has these like massive but oh gosh did the chorus
and then I went to,
they didn't send any better.
I don't want it stop video.
I cannot park but that but toy vibrates so I'm sure that's got to get me off.
It's got this cool.
I'm going to vomit.
I'm going to,
mom is cool.
I saw a friend of mine and he fucks it with his boyfriend and so I really want
to try this because I like fucking stuff at first.
I'm going to try and get this in my butt and then turn it out and it's here.
Got this cool little,
it's pretty welcome.
It's got a nice texture to it.
I think it'll
easy to go in.
I don't know.
Can we pause this please?
Can we pause?
I need a minute.
Watch this.
We're maybe halfway through all the clips.
Yeah,
I know.
I can we just pause.
I'm going to throw up.
I made some Mcdonald's,
but I got to take a minute here.
I got it.
I think I'm blind.
I don't like it.
Hey,
what the fuck is happening?
Is this going to with this shit?
Where is it doing this?
He's putting something in his head.
I don't like any of this.
I don't know.
This cool guy,
ed
made this video.
He did not post it on youtube.
This was on a hardcore sex.
Sorry,
I was just Josh potters thing.
Oh Shit.
No,
no.
I was given the,
uh,
the great benefit of having this email to me and somebody wrote,
I'd love to give them credit.
They wrote 'em Hey,
I saw this video.
It seems awesome and perfect for your show.
And I was like,
all right,
I'll see what this is.
I started to laugh so hard that I forwarded it and then a dob told me,
he's like,
I spent a lot of time a cropping cause he's,
he's got a hard on the whole time and he's straight
jerking off.
Grab the entire video.
Today when I was looking over the clips,
I noticed that there were some spots that I missed so I had to go back.
You'll see it.
Yeah,
I thought so.
Cause his other hand is doing something the whole time.
Then he starts doing something.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
what is this animal doing though right now though?
Freeze framed here in studio with his uh,
legs coming back.
I got it.
That's why I had to stop and take a minute because my lunch is coming up.
There's nothing more disgusting to me than an a man at this angle.
Do you know what I'm saying?
With his leg up and his foot in the frame.
Yeah.
It's so disgusting.
It's cool though that he provides this service to the community.
Then I got these toys.
I've got to review them for you.
Nobody going how they work.
Nobody needs him to do any of this.
By the way though.
Let's start with you regularly.
Cause he's so comfortable.
He's like,
hey guys,
I'm back.
You know,
it's like,
like those guys that opened like a,
you know,
like I got the new Samsung Galaxy.
Like check it out.
Yeah.
So he's doing his review.
Well,
he's nude.
He's shirtless.
He's completely naked.
He's got a crazy tan.
Like you could tell he goes a tan tanning beds and wears like his little speedos
in there.
Um,
but let's see how this stuff works.
Background is hideous too.
He's got like
an ass
I'm going to throw up.
I can't.
It does have kind of a good size head.
So it may take me a minute.
Okay.
Take your time.
But
since my last uh,
but toy video.
Oh,
okay.
So you do do this a lot.
Oof.
Take it in.
Oh yeah.
I've said this before with [inaudible].
If you're new to it,
we got to go slow.
Don't try and rush it.
Yeah.
They'll try and go too fast.
I said a little hurt.
Trust me
once.
Uh,
once you get used to it,
you learn how to breathe and relax yourself.
Yeah.
Play can be a lot of fun.
Sure.
Okay.
I can't take this pretty comfortable in there.
Okie doke.
Thanks.
Okay.
Oh,
nice.
That's a nice feel to it.
Stop.
Oh,
please.
No,
I'm going to die up.
Dying.
I'm dead.
Weight Kik.
Why do they call it?
He's always like,
they're always like,
but play and then I'm like,
Ooh,
this hurts.
Like what?
Part of that play implies fun and pleasure and they're always like,
oh,
it hurts going in play,
but play.
It's not play playground play implies probably,
but it is.
It's fun.
There's just a little discomfort at first.
This heads pretty big.
Yeah.
Ah,
ah.
I haven't had this feeling since the last,
but plug video.
I made a man.
He's a UHF.
He's really,
yeah.
Yeah.
How do you get to this point in your life?
Like what's happened up until now?
Obviously this guy is like,
this is a good idea for me to do on the Internet,
and he's got to get positive feedback about it.
Tons.
Yeah.
I mean,
people are like,
Hey,
what do you,
Hey Jimmy,
what do you make it another bit?
Terry,
he's a Terry.
I feel like Terri Terri make another video this week or what?
But how do you get this comfortable with it?
You know,
I imagine the first one,
he's a little timid doing it a lot.
That's the thing,
like with practice practice,
it's like he was saying,
you don't shove a deck in there the first time he's into it.
Okay,
cool.
So now he's making videos all the time.
I got to say decent camera.
The angles not flattering or not flattering that I like lighting.
Not Great.
Yeah,
background,
not great.
Yeah.
He's got his teeth,
which is disappointing.
Yes.
Go ahead and let's watch the end of this.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Try and turn it on the remote.
Does it seem to work,
at least when I first tried it with turning down,
it just cycles through the steps,
so,
oh,
that's just a constant,
that's even higher.
Yeah,
that's like a throbbing,
I'm going to try out the sleep now and like I said,
I'm really kind of disappointed that this won't be vibrating too,
but I think this thing going off in my book do you like?
Yeah,
it's going to be okay.
And this has some really weird knobbies.
I mean inside there.
Okay.
All loving place.
Awesome.
Okay.
Really upset.
How much shit is he going to put on him and it his bought and in his deck.
I mean,
I keep waiting for it to end like how much shit are you going to put up your
butt and around your deck and on Your Business?
The last clip on your balls like really nicely.
No thanks.
I'm done.
Well,
we gotta wait.
Hello?
I'm going to,
I can't take it.
My brain's overloading.
Yeah.
I can't,
I'm out.
Whoa,
whoa.
Wow.
It's pretty tight.
I wasn't expecting that.
Oh,
that's cool.
Cool feature.
Okay.
Dammit.
Oh,
oh fuck.
Oh fuck.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Ah,
ah,
ah
damn.
It
dammit.
So I think that's what you call it ruined orgasm because I look at this cat and
it felt really good and that thing was in my boat,
just set me off that wasn't expecting it.
So I want to try this again with the vibrators.
Um,
the bullets.
Cool.
And then of course,
having a buddy to do it with me Sunday would be nice.
Really fucking awesome.
Yeah.
Take care of you guys.
I hope you enjoyed that.
We definitely enjoyed that.
Terry.
I don't know.
Fucking killed it,
Brian.
I think he needs a mattress too.
It doesn't look like not in that apartment because he had me eat you the cat.
Every,
everything is so fucked up,
baby.
Huh?
I really think
God that,
I mean we've seen so much on the show.
Where does that right?
That was right over the limit,
but I think I'm,
that was
like,
I think I've tapped out of the show.
What was the worst part?
Oh,
all of it.
Like just watching him blow his load,
he was like,
oh,
this is so great.
I'm like,
I'm going to call it God damn it.
Why didn't you show me that?
Cause I thought I would do that.
Don't you love me anymore?
Yeah,
of course you love me.
Yes,
of course.
Why would you do this to me?
Because it was funny.
It was funny to watch him and it was funny.
Or to watch you watch him.
You're the worst.
I know how to make myself laugh.
Oh my God.
That
really,
that really for me,
hands down easily.
The highlight of 29
yeah.
I feel like I need a nap.
Like I'm emotionally exhausted.
Me Too.
I haven't laughed that hard in a fucking wild.
Oh my God,
this is terrible.
I wasn't gonna say we should show our guests,
but I'm not sure she needs to see it.
I think she would have loved to think we need to share it with another woman.
She likes cool guys.
I think she likes to cool guys.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
That was so cool.
The cat,
the cat was the best.
The cat at the end.
Who doesn't know what the fuck is going on?
What does that,
what do you think that room smells like?
That room definitely has a funk to it.
He's got a butt plug.
It smells,
you know what smells like?
It smells like bleach in there cause he's probably always like,
that guy probably had aids.
I don't know.
I'm going to clean this up for sure.
There's problems in that room,
but he's also an outdoorsman.
You actually need an emotional break.
Wow.
I've never seen this
before.
Like something really trauma reaction.
Like
when he changes on die,
die,
he pulled his legs up.
There is no worse position on a human man.
Yeah.
I think we've done it as a joke where you pull your legs back and I just pretend
to change it.
They get home is as a joke and it's so horrible.
I took a lot of battery.
It took a lot out of it.
I feel like we're like,
our work here is done.
And that was the Lord's work here in your mom's house?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Oh yeah.
What a nightmare.
Yeah,
it was really something,
man.
Oh God.
I'm scarred and thanks Tommy.
And that was neat.
I've been wanting to,
you got your prostate exam coming up.
Do you think this was good preparation for that?
So,
yeah.
You know,
he really like,
we can't say his name.
No,
but,
um,
it's our doctor.
Yeah,
he really does.
I've talked about them in my act before and specials Dr Deck.
Yeah,
he really is.
And he really does do that.
He really did that last year to me,
the he,
he goes,
um,
take a deep breath and I was like,
okay.
And you're,
the thing is,
when that's happening to you,
it's never been done before.
Right.
So,
um,
we mean your first time.
Yeah.
The first process.
I've never had that.
Sure.
You're,
you're really,
I mean,
you're naked,
you're in the fetal position and you have this
almost,
I wouldn't say you have shame,
but you're,
you know,
you're,
it's almost like you're embarrassed a little bit and your,
um,
you just want,
you want it to be over.
I know.
And you wish that,
um,
every woman listening is like,
we go through this,
I get it.
The speculum pursuit.
And then
if you have children,
it's so demeaning.
That's it.
It feels kinds of meanings.
I'm just staring at the wall and,
uh,
he's like,
I'm all right and take a deep breath.
I'm like,
okay.
And he's like,
there's plenty of lube here.
I go,
okay.
And he goes,
and you're just gonna feel slight pressure.
That is my cock my finger too.
And I just start laughing.
I'm laughing.
Yeah.
As I'm his fingers clamping.
And then he's like,
and when I,
when I,
what he's done,
he,
uh,
I still laughing.
I turned around to look at him and he goes,
uh,
like he pretends that he's,
he switched hands.
He's like,
ah,
ridiculous.
So I'm sure he's really a fantastic doctor though.
Yeah,
I know.
Um,
he is,
he has the best doc.
He's so thorough.
Yeah.
No,
he really is.
I trust him more than I press it.
Any other doc?
Yeah,
we've had,
but,
uh,
that,
that's very rude of him.
He's incredibly,
that's incredibly,
he has said the wildest shit to me.
I mean,
things that I haven't said in my act,
you know,
one time I saw him when I had a sinus infection and I still remember I was going
to India,
I was going to play crackers in Indy and I get on,
I get in his office and I'm like,
he checked me out.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
it's bad.
You know,
you're,
you're sick.
And I go,
that was that time where you're like,
you put your little shows ahead of your health.
Yeah,
of course.
That was like,
I have to get on this plane.
He was like,
you definitely shouldn't fly.
And I go,
I'm flying.
Is there anything I can do to improve my chances?
And he goes,
yeah,
sit at a window seat and you'll sit on a window seat.
And he goes,
yeah,
left window.
Excuse me.
I go,
why?
He said,
well,
you have an infection in your left ear,
so if you sit on your left window when your eardrum ruptures,
it will splatter all over the window.
And he just looks at me.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
It's like,
well,
that's what you could do.
Yeah,
I go,
okay,
thanks.
Shit like that.
Yeah,
he's bright.
He's blunt cause he's right.
He's right.
Of course he was right and that was one of the worst decisions I made to fly to
fly or do those show.
Oh my God,
I know.
So,
so your,
your drum did not rupture.
It did not rupture,
but I got really sick.
I know.
It's terrible.
One time I got on a plane,
I got the phone call that I had my urine tested and they're like,
there's blood in your urine.
And I was like,
what?
I got to get on this flight to San Francisco and I gotten that.
I did shows pes and blood and like,
what are we thinking?
Like just to become comedians.
It's just,
you're terrified.
You're terrified.
That $300 I get to get on this plane.
Yeah.
You're just so scared.
But you're going to see him.
When is that?
Tomorrow.
Yeah.
What time is your exam?
All right.
Be Thinking about you.
Thanks.
I have to get fat fingered.
Uh,
no.
You better eat your Mcdonald's now I'm going to here.
I'm going to have like six servings of Mcdonald's before I go to bed,
you know,
so that I'm nice and stuff for my physical
like that.
Uh,
he's going to like hearing that you're on a Mcdonald's diet and be like,
I don't really have a choice man.
It's Mcdonald's time,
you know,
so it's the new sponsor,
the new sponsor,
and we couldn't be more thrilled.
Um,
oh,
worthy.
A homeowner's nation.
Sorry.
No,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
I was going to tell you that over the holiday,
you know,
in La we have what's called the Rose Parade and we were hanging out at the
house.
We didn't do much this Christmas holiday.
We've got two little children,
so we just stayed home and farted around.
But uh,
you know,
I,
we were in the house and I jokingly was like,
Oh,
you know,
we haven't done today's watch,
the Rose Parade,
because that is one of the most fucking boring things.
It's like,
it takes place in Pasadena every year and people line up and spend the night,
like nights on end to see the fucking floats go by.
And I've seen the floats on close.
They're really nice like it is.
I understand.
Unbelievable.
If they choose to do that,
well that's what she's slapping cause you're like,
oh my God,
that sounds like the worst thing ever.
Hands down the thing.
I think if I were to make a list of things that I find the dumbest,
least appealing to me,
this would be in the top three too.
Yeah.
I would rather go to like Lala Palooza.
Fucking Coachella at burning man.
Yeah.
All those things.
There was a village I saw of a Coachella show,
I think it was last year that had upwards of 250,000 people.
That one of the shows.
I'm like,
oh that's,
that seems cool.
Like to have a quarter million people around you.
Well how do you take a piss and they're all drinking beer piss right there.
What do you mean?
How do you know for sure they do it just piss right.
You know how much piss and shit is probably on the grounds of those things.
Well at burning man more dignified.
Little bit,
but then,
but where do they pissing and shitting in the dye dyes that were Dido's look at
this lunatic,
these psychos.
And I'm not,
I'm sorry to say it.
God,
I hope you don't mind.
You're not upset,
but there's a,
there's a lot of chicks out there that lead the way,
right?
Cues are really are.
No,
no,
no.
Really.
I don't understand why everyone wants a fucking stupid.
Okay.
Can we not start?
That's the last thing we need.
Yeah,
no,
no.
This is,
this is,
this is universal.
These are idiots everywhere.
Men and women know they are to see floats.
I mean,
I couldn't think of anything worse.
Three days and in the cold they're doing this shit over Christmas.
It gets cold at night
there.
Yeah,
very,
very cold.
I mean,
it's,
um,
yeah,
I can't think of anything I care about that much to spend the night for,
you know,
even people that do that for black Friday sales,
they sleep out on the sidewalk for like nights before.
It's crazy.
It's totally crazy.
Is there anything in this world you get 10% off more if you sleep outside
tonight?
Yeah.
Like,
but thinking about how memorable broke by the way roque wanting things and just
been like,
I guess it's not for me
and now the people are like,
oh all I had to do sleep outside on the sidewalk overnight.
Oh you get 20% off.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thinking about the misery of sitting outside in the dark and the cold.
There's nothing on this planet.
Like if someone said,
look,
your children's lives depend on that and be like,
yeah,
absolutely.
But short of that and they don't,
there's nothing in the world that can make me do and that parade shit.
Like what do you get out of that?
The what?
Will you sleep when you sleep outside?
Correct.
No,
I got front row as the people walk by and people will wave at us and then we get
to see the float and then you ever watch channel seven news,
the guy and the girl to do that.
They'll be right there too.
What the fuck is wrong with you nailed it.
That's exactly what they want.
It's like then and then waving,
then they wave and you can wave.
Last year,
you know,
uh,
Cheryl for channel five,
she waved.
She waved right at me.
Okay.
Is that a good time?
And it's like you've got television,
you can see it on TV.
You don't have to,
you mean like in a high def and with cutaways and you sit on your couch and you
drink a fucking hot cocoa.
Have a hot dog or the newer house,
Macy's Thanksgiving parade.
People stand for that shit too.
I can't imagine anything.
We'll talk about those pieces of shit.
They go to times square for New Year's.
Fuck.
You know,
the absolute and how regs of humanity,
if we have a plague,
we should drop it in Times Square and wipe those people first.
That's who dies first.
Yeah.
Well,
and especially because in June,
Dork titties,
it's so cold.
I mean,
could you imagine a worse place in the country to be out at
midnight on New Year's Eve?
You out of your fucking mind.
It's really crazy.
You to be out of your fucking mind.
You know when I was there I saw,
yeah,
that's right.
True.
It is true.
When I was in judo titties at the beginning of December,
they had the stupid thing where it's like a Santa's pub crawl and I saw all
these idiot frat boys dressed up as Santa says,
and the girls dressed up as Elvis and they just go bar hopping or whatever and
they're all in the middle of the fucking day.
How fucking stupid is that one too?
I mean,
I met a kill my way that people like the creativity that people would need as an
excuse to drink.
Oh,
I know.
It's down to,
it's like,
just have a fucking drink.
You could do it any day dog part of the festival.
It's a,
it's a 10 K and you
got to drink it like,
dude,
just,
just drink to get drunk.
You know,
you're an adult and you can get hammered at all times or times.
You should,
if that's,
if that's what you're thinking about you,
you should,
yeah,
you should go to times square.
You should fucking live there.
And I get drunk.
Well you think Bert ever asks himself,
do I deserve this beer now?
He just drinks and all the time,
all day,
every day.
There's never a no.
It was never,
there's never the thought I shouldn't drink.
Is there a big Mac?
Absolutely.
All the time.
Of course.
You need them whenever I want.
Yeah,
of course,
man.
You got it.
Thanks to our sponsor,
our great,
great sponsor.
Mcdonald's.
Yes.
Okay.
What'd you rather and I'm being serious.
Yeah,
it's burning man or,
or New Year's Eve in Times Square.
Which of the two?
Okay.
Fuck.
I think I,
I hate the heat more than the cold,
but I think that would have to take new years.
Serious.
I think so.
Yeah.
I think,
I think so.
I'm trying to,
I mean,
I like music more than I like a fucking crystal ball dropping boring.
But the idea of being with those people,
music festival really,
really?
Now I know somebody who goes,
I know a couple people that go to these cylons.
Yeah.
Like regular,
like art and Arrigo.
Arie likes those kinds of things.
He goes to a,
what's the Tennessee one?
Bonnaroo.
Yeah.
Another horrible nightmare is when they're like,
you know,
they have a comedy tent and you can,
you can get booked and you can go to all the shows for free.
And I'm like [inaudible].
You could also just inject heroin into my asshole.
I could just pass out where I'm sitting right now.
Especially when you hear things like the comedy tent comedy should never be done
in a tent.
I've done it a few times.
I don't like it outdoors.
Nope,
I don't like it intense and I don't like it on a music festival.
No.
Matter of fact,
I don't even like it at a comedy festival.
I like shows and then I like to leave.
I hate,
you know,
my fucking what I hate the most about a comedy festival when they go,
uh,
it's a great hang though.
I'm like a great hang and they're like,
yeah,
you like,
you can hang out with all the other comics.
I'm like,
yeah,
I could do that whenever I want.
I'm actually like,
I can pick the ones I want to hang out with.
I have this phone,
I can text like people I like,
like,
oh yeah,
you go to the festival and you could hang out with everyone.
Right.
Here's the deal man though about your choice now.
New Year's Eve.
Yeah.
It's one night with drunk idiots essentially.
Burning man.
It's over the stretch.
Let's say a week at burning man.
Yes,
it's hot,
but there's like burning man.
That's okay.
I thought it was talking about it compared to a music that's not a music
festival.
No burning man.
It's like dirty hippies.
And then you're saying that versus,
it's like a bunch of computer nerds who once a year they go to burning man.
They do a bunch of drugs and then they make floats
and they ride bicycles half and they're like,
have an orgasm contest and then like nasty people eat each other out in the
dirt.
It's on Applia.
So the sand is very sticky and it's unhygienic and there's,
you know,
you have to use Porta potties to shit and piss and,
okay.
Right.
I think I'm decided.
So in New York you're still going to do Jews or Katie rule that.
Yeah man,
of course.
Okay.
Yeah.
Terrible.
What about,
well hold on,
let me just think.
Would you rather do burning man or you sit and wait for the Rose Parade and
that's a,
it's it's a week waiting for the rose praying week cause you have to do a
weekend either climate.
Either get the fuck out of here.
It's a week at burning man or a week waiting for the Rose Parade.
Those good and see how many people I could get pregnant.
I would just be like,
let's see if I'm in like I have tests at the end of the tube and if you got
pregnant like that,
that's easy.
That's easy.
Yeah.
They have to wear them and they have to wear their,
their crop top.
So I'll be like,
you're the sluts.
Okay.
Yeah.
Why don't choose burning man.
You would as much as I am feeding them in there.
Like a fucking real SLU team.
Not as a,
as a show I worked on,
I worked on a television show.
We filmed there,
I swear to God I would do it.
Aim here.
What was the show called?
The show is called the hitchhiker chronicles on Fx.
It was the lead and show to hurt bird actually before I was friends with Bert
Kreischer.
Wow.
And we picked up hitchhikers when we did Bernie under 300 pounds.
When that show,
those are his skinny,
he's lean days.
You would really check the would take,
why would you take a week there?
I don't like the cold,
the cold cold.
And I can just imagine the inane conversations I'd be having on the parade
trail.
Here's the thing,
I could also get really high.
You have to fight on the parade trail.
Just like shut down and just,
you know,
let my eyes roll back and like wake up a couple of days later.
Like what's going on with your,
I like,
Yo,
what happened?
Well it's Thursday and like,
Oh shit,
there's the parade's about to start.
Yeah man,
you're just laying in your own piss.
You've been like this for days.
But she could do that at burning man and stay warm.
Can I get my little tent though?
Like they do.
Some people have tests.
I do the little tent thing,
but you have to send up packet for Mcdonald's and sleeping bags,
but you have to have a chair.
You know how they have their beach chairs too?
I would have a tent and I would have like my chair and my foot and then I would
have hardcore porn plan on it so that people would start to spread away from my
tent.
She get a little more space that would happen to burning man.
They'd be like,
oh,
that guy is just Jackie Knauf.
Yeah,
let's get a space.
I don't think.
I think they'd be,
well,
let's hang out with in Pasadena.
They'd be like,
call the police.
Great.
I love to get out of here.
Take me to jail.
That's my a way out of this.
They don't tolerate that monkey business and Pasadena.
No,
they don't.
They don't.
Um,
why don't we take a quick break again?
No,
our guest is going to arrive,
so eat a filet of fish.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm again,
once again,
of course.
Thanks to uh,
are great friends and our sponsors at Mcdonald's
and we're back after that much needed break,
everybody peed.
And now we are joined by a comedian and also a fellow degenerate.
You mean comedian?
A lovely and delightful comedian lady.
A lady comic.
Everybody a glitter cheese herself is a trigger.
Everybody,
thank you for coming.
Thank you.
But when people introduce you for spots,
do they sometimes say I'm despicable or deplorable?
People say all weird words.
Can't remember.
Degender Hep.
They say you're from your mom's home,
and then they just go from Netflix.
I think that's probably easier.
I had a guy,
a drunk guy in the lobby go,
uh,
he goes,
oh,
like I was walking through the lobby and San Diego.
He goes,
go,
hey.
He goes,
dude,
don't tell me.
And I go,
okay.
He's like,
I'm drunk.
I go,
okay.
He goes,
mom's pot house.
That's it.
It's mom's pot house.
Or we had that lady who was like,
Oh my God,
I'm obsessed with you guys.
I watch you every day.
Day.
Yeah.
When people compliment you and then they're like,
what's your name though?
Do you get recognized every day?
He does a lot.
Just depends where you are though,
you know,
like,
um,
first of all sometimes you're like,
oh no.
Then you realize like,
oh,
we were home all day today.
So,
uh,
but I think like high population areas,
you know,
if you go to,
once you start traveling,
like if we're in or it's like we're in like a Beverly hills,
like in the center of activity,
there's so many people.
It's like being at an airport.
So you,
you know,
recognize more.
They're obviously,
but shopping
and Jude are titties.
That's where you live.
Do people recognize you a lot from the show?
From now?
Degenerates.
Just once in a while.
It's usually like a fun gal that's on par from New York though too.
I feel like New York's not going to be like [inaudible] recently in San
Francisco with a friend and her friends came to meet us and they couldn't
believe I was there and they were like,
you really know each other.
And that felt kind of fun.
That's cool.
Um,
so she was happy.
We have mutual friends,
but it might say I live in crown heights and um,
in the past couple of months through the carbon monoxide alarm has gone off
three times.
And the landlords being kind of a bitch about it.
It won't fix him getting defensive and yelling and the plumber,
it keeps fixing stuff,
but it keeps going off.
There's poisonous gases.
We found out the building next door had squatters.
They broke into our basement and set up generators and so those,
so the landlord was being not so nice,
but she was also like nothing is wrong with the building.
And I'm like,
you're,
I'm going to complain,
I'm taking you to court.
And then I just found out that it was squatters with generators,
cheese,
people squat,
people who don't have a place.
Yes.
We're able to get into a building.
Yeah.
And Hook up a generator.
And then live in the building next door and then,
and they're powering it from your,
from the gender.
And then there was a gas leak upstairs.
So basically just almost murdering us for months also speaks to the ingenuity of
New Yorkers.
And I'm going to stay in the apartment.
Like that to me was the best case scenario then it wasn't the building's
problems.
So I'm like what did they do?
Nothing.
They finally kick these people out.
Well No,
the cops were just like,
cause I was on a plane and the neighbor called me.
He's like,
guess what?
This is this happened.
And uh,
they said the squatters might come back to watch out.
They can't guarantee the squatters won't come back.
Now here's a great generator.
He I think got rid of it,
but that didn't break my door down cause I was at the airport on a plane.
So they broke my door down,
gotten to the basement and found the generators.
Did you do you know in La,
by the way,
in the state of California,
the squatters have rights and there's like a protocol to kicking them out.
You can't just be like,
get the fuck out of my property.
I also would just not want to ever be a landlord was learning about like how it
varies state to state,
but you can rent to somebody and they can just be like,
I'm in certain states,
I'm not paying,
I'm not paying you.
And then the process to a victim can be like,
yeah,
fuck yeah,
but most landlords aren't good people.
Really?
Yeah.
Maybe that's in New York.
Cause my other one,
he wouldn't give me my deposit,
but like I told him the heat wasn't working and he came back with a device and
like he was like,
I don't know,
it's fine.
I'm like,
I'm wearing a coat inside.
Like I don't know.
They don't,
they think that people are trying to scam them and it's like I'm just cold or
there's just monoxide,
like I just don't want to die.
She kept being like,
the plumber said it's safe,
the fire department said it's fine,
why would it's fine.
And I go,
it's just not worth the risk.
I don't know.
And she's like,
just stay there.
And then I'm glad I did.
And they went to a friend's house and then the next day was full,
like left the carbon monoxide levels.
We're at 35 and they should be zero woo.
And I was just sleeping there.
I've been sleeping with windows open all winter cause I'm just so terrified of
dying.
That's terrible.
Yeah.
I moved to La.
I can't yet.
We're not done with the New York,
New York.
It's just too far.
And I come here enough that when we met,
we met in Chicago and Peoria,
Peoria at the jukebox.
Then we did Schomburg together.
I,
my friend opened for you.
I just came to watch.
Yes,
but we've talked about the clock.
Yeah.
What's the neatest part?
Is that when you're doing your show the dirt track gears up and then you can
hear the cars unless you're killin.
No one's really there though.
That's part of the club too.
There's no one there.
And he punches holes in the wall.
Yeah,
he's wild.
But I do have like these fantasies of like making it big and going back to
Peoria and being like,
I'm going to sell out for you.
But yeah,
you want to a part of me.
Is that all about we know.
I don't know.
You all show you piece of shit.
No,
not in a bad way at all.
It's just like wild to see.
He,
he won't book like Youtube Stars because of integrity and I'm like,
just get them in here.
Yeah.
Sell the speech.
He's like,
should I have the real housewife on?
I'm like,
have her here sell tickets.
Well it's also like don't,
yeah,
don't judge it.
If people like it,
it's entertainment.
Who gives a shit?
Just do it.
Yes sir.
I'll get my space here.
It's so fucking cold in here.
Are you cold?
Okay.
For right now.
I'll probably put my denim on where you are.
You from there though?
No,
I'm from the Chicago suburbs.
Yeah,
that's what I thought.
Stokey oh,
very Jewy known for Nazi marches.
KKK marches.
Oh,
we have a good library.
So it's a nice blend of Jews in Nazi marches.
Yeah.
The Nazis used to come all the time cause I had the biggest population of Jews
outside of Israel.
And then when I was in school,
the KKK would march and then we'd have discussions in school about freedom of
speech.
I love boy.
Yeah.
Kind of supercharges yesterday.
It was a diverse neighborhood.
It was fun.
So now you also mentioned that you're going to do the AVN awards.
Yes.
What are you going to do?
Hello?
Can you tell who that is?
As a Ramone?
Namar no.
Wow.
Okay.
That's really specific for men.
Know who has those Rocco's if ready.
You're,
you're familiar.
Yeah.
Would you like to watch this documentary?
Of course.
Yeah.
I did.
Annabella dangers in it.
Who is one of my faves.
Yeah.
Um,
but he's a Weirdo.
Yeah.
I mean he's like creep.
He's a demon.
He's a dean.
He is a sexy piece is kids are like 17 and they're like,
Dad,
are you going to stop
now?
It's your turn to the point.
They're like,
we don't want to do,
they'll,
a lot of them have kids.
It's a lot.
That's why I asked.
Once you have kids,
you start thinking about that.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Well,
cause I'm even nervous about our boys watching this show.
Yeah,
yeah.
I want a decade or so.
But could you imagine doing pornography and his kids?
Like they,
they're at that age,
they know that their dad doesn't just have sex.
Yeah.
But that he is the step on girls' necks.
Put toes in their ass is and just like go to like he is the,
he's the sex Satan basically.
No,
I,
that's one of my pet peeve porn pet peeves is when there's like a random foot,
I don't like it.
Yeah.
I don't like a foot in the mouth.
All of a sudden someone's looking at toe like I don't need to warn.
Yeah.
I have a few pet peeves,
but that's okay.
I got some shit.
What's your,
I don't like grundle shots.
What's that like from the back?
What the ball's waving.
Like I don't want to see man butts.
I agree with napping.
I don't want to see that.
And I don't like when it's like a giant gaping,
but,
and you can look inside.
I don't like,
uh,
yeah,
the gate.
I don't like the gaping butts either.
I got to tell you when they're like,
look,
and then it starts to just feel like surgery.
Mattamy it becomes,
yeah,
it shifts from any type of sexual thing to like,
that's what it looks like in there.
It's it.
Same thing.
Like I don't want to see a camera go down into the throat.
Oh Wow.
That's my pet peeve is the choking.
Gagging just doesn't feel voluntary a lot to me.
We got to face fucking,
is that what that's called?
Yeah.
I don't like that.
You always into porn?
No.
Um,
but as a grown up,
like I would say in my twenties,
that's why I don't think it fucked with my brain too much out there.
Cause that's when,
that's when I started really tart kink dot coms like my favorite.
But I know all right.
Is that fetish stuff?
Yeah.
What's the,
what are you into?
My favorite channel is public disgrace.
What's that?
My therapist has ruined everything for me.
But uh,
well yeah,
she said it's our brain takes trauma from our youth and makes it fantasy and
that's like why we're into what we're into,
which is upsetting.
Um,
but she's like,
no,
it's,
our brain is magical.
But I'm like,
no,
it's like sad that,
but I like when they take like a girl and there's like a dominatrix girl and
then everyone kind of fucks her at a bar and like passes her and I,
they pour beer on her.
That's interesting.
See
public disgrace.
I could kick a guy in the nuts and feel good about that.
Like those videos where the guy gets kicked him.
Like I could do that easy piece.
Um,
yeah.
I for a girl needs to be degraded,
but I can't just have men around.
Like there needs to be a female in charge.
Yes,
that makes sense to me too.
I don't like lesbian porn.
I think for me,
well I'm kind of newly sort of gay.
I had an ex girlfriend and I think I'm getting,
so I dated a girl like maybe a year and a half ago for about six months.
I got dumped.
It ruined my life.
That's what I started therapy.
But I think I'm more gay than I ever anticipated.
So I want to find a girlfriend and because I'm new to it,
I've been watching and learning from.
And you're saying you're not interested in men at all at this point because all,
but I would like a wife,
but I'm not,
not like I find men hot sometimes.
Oh,
well that's good.
Uh,
I would fuck a dude.
I feel like I can't see myself ending up with a guy bisexual though right now.
I think so,
yeah.
I'm open.
I want to be like,
I want to be in love.
I want to find a partner.
I want to be married.
I wanted that for us.
That's what I walk signing.
You should.
Yeah.
No,
I don't.
Polyamory is like losers to me.
I don't like the word.
I don't like the,
like I don't,
it's just like I want love.
I want to be married and have like a dog.
But you're definitely,
from what I'm hearing,
I really like dating a girl.
You're channeling the energy towards women.
Yeah.
Like on the dating Apps,
I'm all,
I'm looking for only girls.
Well,
I got to tell you something,
but in the life,
because here's the thing,
what I of course am,
I am a fan of yours.
I said we both are Tom.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm just speaking from myself,
but yes,
we're fans of yours.
Uh,
nothing would make me happier than to see you happy.
And I want you to find the love of your life purpose.
Well,
there's no reason to be.
What I'm going to do is,
are you currently single?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm very single.
I haven't had sex in a year.
Okay.
I'm so glad you're here.
I'm going to throw at you some different men who are available and even though
you're putting out there,
I'm respecting the fact that you're saying women,
I would just like you to consider,
you may just give me your take on them as they,
you know,
display themselves to scream.
Okay?
So let's go ahead
before you have sex.
If you want to be horny for two or three hours,
like you never been in your life,
any of access to marijuana too good,
we'd listen to me today.
Turn weight alone.
Can get you really hornier than normal.
But it's been an in general take about 10,
12,
Benham girl before you want to have your sexual fun with your partner or
whatever you do or masturbate.
All right.
Yeah.
Uh,
about an hour later when you fill it,
just kicking and smoke your weed done and then can go ahead and get horny.
And I promise you it will be millions of times more.
You'll be so blissfully horny that you will not want to come.
Trust me.
So is this the fam?
Uh,
we hope so.
We're fans.
It is.
You know,
would you do,
would you go to dinner huffing?
Yeah,
I do like his beard.
but I'm positive outlook that guy has.
I don't like the snorts that he was doing.
What?
I'm sorry.
What do you mean?
The snorts like he made like breathe like,
you know what's funny?
I don't like snoring.
We had a,
Oh,
I see.
That's what turned you off.
The other,
the 10 to 12 Benadryl and then the word,
the setting,
the way that it looks good to me.
Where do you find these?
We're lucky.
The best fans in the world.
That guy,
by the way,
um,
he has,
some respiratory issues.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but I figured you could help them.
You know,
maybe like one of the things you would do is we'll in the oxygen every day as
part of the new relationship.
No,
Gosh,
I don't know.
I'm not good at like Improv Games.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's totally,
we just,
we want to find love for you.
What if like,
let's say,
let's take this scenario took place.
Um,
you meet a guy,
he's like,
Lisa,
and you're like,
what?
And do I know you?
And he's like,
ah,
nothing.
I just,
I know I,
I've seen you on Netflix and anyways,
would you like to have dinner some time?
And you're like,
I don't,
I dunno man.
I'm kind of not.
And then he goes,
this,
let me have your number.
And then you give them your phone.
He takes it,
he puts his number in,
but he calls himself so he now has your number,
right.
Kind of a slick move.
That's what this guy did.
And then the next morning he just sent a video of himself to this girl who he'd
met one time.
Okay,
I'm thrilled.
Ready?
Yes.
Good morning,
Julia.
It's me.
Joe.
Just wanted to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that me and you yesterday and getting a look at you was probably one of
the greatest moments of my life.
You are so beautiful.
You don't know how beautiful you are to me.
I mean just,
you're gorgeous.
You're precious.
But it's been sitting in my mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with your ex boyfriend,
please erase him from your memory.
Don't ever go back in the past.
I know,
cause I've been there and I understand when you know you're trying to find
somebody and you go on dates and not the compares to your racks,
but there is that better person out there.
And Julia,
I promise you it is me.
I mean so far I love you like you've never been loved before.
You feel terrified.
Um,
not to.
I liked it.
He's showing off his home,
the whole thing.
I like the plant.
No,
I hate the word precious a lot.
Yeah,
I hate that.
Do you like ceiling fans though?
He's got multiple ceilings.
No.
Yeah,
a lot.
No,
I got some sheik fans actually.
Yeah,
I have some Varnado for Nedo cause that offensive brand.
It's a fancy fan brand.
Really?
Yeah,
I like it.
I did buy the Dyson Airblade one too,
but I thought it was an air conditioner and they're not there.
Just $600 fans owe $600 I bought two.
Yeah,
there like three 50 each and I thought they were air conditioners but they're
just air filtering fan.
So I returned them immediately.
Oh yeah,
that's no.
Yeah.
Someone that I had a crush on told me to buy them and I did it.
And then can I ask you though,
would you re,
do you respect this move of the gun?
No,
no,
no.
This is too much.
Right.
But you know the answer though.
Yeah.
Sending a video the next day.
Also,
I'm,
I hate when people are like,
you don't know how beautiful you are.
That's so weird.
I don't like that.
It is rude.
And the,
the hair on his face looks weird.
It looks like it's too smooth everywhere.
And then just so Perry and travel.
Yeah.
I don't like this at all.
It's a little intense to write.
Very intense.
It's a lot for a chording video and he doesn't know.
No.
Yes,
no,
but yet,
no one would agree with that.
This is a good move though,
right?
I don't think anyone,
except for Joe,
he thinks it's a good movie and is a great mood.
Yeah.
I wonder what he does for a living.
It is a nice place.
Wow.
Yeah.
I wonder,
do you know where he lives?
I do.
Okay.
As a mall town.
No big cities.
So he is making money.
He makes a good living.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's pretty good.
Now this is crazy.
In that region out to them.
And then we were like,
ah,
good idea.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's go.
I don't like Gel met.
There's just better products out there.
There's pomades and creams.
There's no reason to use a gel.
Sure.
Dated at this point.
Like if you're,
if you're doing gel,
you're like,
I'm a Guido.
Yeah.
Fucking Guinea wop.
So this guys,
sorry,
I don't want to
see if you liked this one.
A shot.
No,
I'm done.
Fucking old man.
I like to have some on my lips.
I would've liked to have
titties.
Your roadmap.
I would like to have some sex.
I like to have a woman in my home.
I could make her look.
I'm not like one of these young men are little boys.
They get their selves off and then oops,
they don't care about their partner.
You come.
Yeah,
but this is what my ab and experience is gonna be.
It's gonna be me interviewing guys like that are going to be like,
I'm just like sick of old white dudes.
Well,
you know the Internet is ruining my life right now.
No,
they found racist tweets and they're really bad.
They're so bad.
It's you really,
I'm so embarrassed.
I can't believe I wrote any of those things.
I'm truly humiliated.
How did someone,
why does someone dig it up?
How did it,
cause I did the MSNBC thing and I said I'm sick of old white guys and Bernie's
old and ugly.
Like,
I just,
but it was just,
I was just excited to go on the show cause chef Tom Colicchio is going to be on
and he's a hero of mine.
My friend was at my house braiding and they sent me topics.
I'm like,
no,
Bernie's annoying.
I'll talk about him.
And then people love Bernie.
So I've been a,
I can't,
I have not gone online in a few days.
That's the tactic like Diane Monoxide Bitch.
But yeah,
the tweets are bad.
I apologize.
But a lot of people don't believe that I'm being sincere.
But there I am humiliated.
But I was just more scared of my friends and my friends that I care about have
texts to me going,
you're fine.
So that's all I really care about because I think every,
almost every comic has some experience in this,
in that if you've had Twitter and you,
Twitter's been around a little over 10 years,
you might have gone from being someone in your young teens in your early
twenties,
thirties.
It's,
um,
you know,
you make jokes that are just,
well,
I also feel dumb because I was told like,
scrub your Twitter.
And I was like,
I don't think I have anything.
I'm like pretty good of a person.
And then I their old though,
I said the n word in 2016.
I don't know what I was thinking cause I knew it was bad then,
but I did it.
Yeah.
Well there's like 15 Asian tweets.
Um,
and then a couple about Indian men on men.
Like I don't know what I was,
I can't even,
but you know what?
If they just posted it going like this dumb white bitch,
I'd be fine with it.
But they're going in,
anyone that's black or Asian that's following me,
they're sending them the screenshots.
Oh Geez.
So I just,
that's kind of weird.
I know,
but I think that like
the kind of interesting psychology two comedians yeah.
Is that like,
even if you,
if you hang out with comics all the time,
um,
you start to,
you build this thing where you go,
it becomes about like,
can you say the,
the thing that gets a reaction out of other comics.
So you start to naturally say more inflammatory things,
not to excuse it.
Like,
yeah,
but like if you hang out with comics,
you'll hear more racial,
sexist,
just crazier language that you don't really don't hear it.
And then you start to think of it as like the norm,
you know?
And then he,
and then you get distance from it and you're like,
oh,
that was pretty reckless way to speak.
Yeah.
But I mean,
at the time you feel like you're just,
you know,
you're being the rascal basically like you're saying,
just to be provocative.
I mean,
isn't that the Gig?
To be provocative and to push the boundaries
also,
this isn't gonna make me like Bernie,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I don't know what these people is kind of a no motivation is,
but I have done a show.
Funny question to ask you guys
as Nicole,
if I say the n word,
is that one of your things?
No,
I would rather be degraded.
I don't want to call anyone that work.
Well,
one person.
So the tweet was about,
so I took accidentally my niece and nephews to see Keanu,
cause I thought it was just a movie about a kitten.
And then it was so many Edwards Strip appeal movies.
Yes.
And so one person tweeted like [inaudible] even care,
she said the word,
but she took children to that movie.
Her judgments obviously fucked.
We can't listen to her about politics.
People aren't just people.
Yeah.
That was better not to read it.
You're smart.
You're approach is,
no,
I'm not.
Yeah.
I'm,
I give him my password to someone and I'm not going on it.
Good for you.
Yeah,
don't do it.
Block it out.
I can't.
Yeah,
they're just a,
there's no more texts.
Let's talk about your porno pet peeves.
What else do I like?
Well,
I hate fake noises.
Yeah,
that's why I like,
I think the pope,
like the kinky stuff,
cause you know it's a little bit more real.
There's like Hitachi's everywhere.
Oh right.
So I like real noises and then sometimes I'm fans of porn stars that don't turn
me on,
but I'm just,
I'm obsessed with them.
Like Adriana Shewchuk,
I just like,
I'm obsessed with,
I don't know how I pay,
I give her 1299 a month,
but I don't use it to masturbate for her only fans cause she's a slut on her off
time.
And that's like the best.
So her only fans account,
it's basically her.
Some of them,
she'll suck a dick at a Dave and busters.
I do jokes like she'll just put her on her,
she'll be at a music festival and she'll just suck a dick in the middle of it
or,
um,
and she gets people on craigslist and they come over and then they have sex with
her.
And then her boyfriend had sex.
She's just like wild when it's her and all her best friends are porn stars.
So they'll have game nights and then she'll just tape them doing whatever.
I like watching her on her off time.
It's almost like if you're watching this like porn stuff and then you see a
behind the scenes,
the behind the scenes seems like it's um,
I don't know,
a little more exciting because like,
yes,
they're not performing,
you know?
Yeah.
And then my favorite girls,
they are lesbian,
married couple,
but they'll get another girl and they'll be in a hotel room in one we'll tape
and the others have sex and I kinda,
yeah,
I like it grounded but not amateur.
I want a professional,
I hate,
they don't know the angles and stuff.
Like I don't want to watch amateur porn.
And you learn this over years of,
right.
Like you said in your 20s or early twenties you got more into it in the past few
years.
I would say I'm lonely.
Yeah.
And I'm into it.
But I also watched the interviews before and after and I watched,
there's like a series called ask a porn star.
So I get to,
I like to know about their translating world.
Lot of work would you ever do on,
it sounds like you're very interested in I would world.
I would never,
uh,
but I see in my private life,
I like it.
So I am terrified at any moment that someone will release something that's going
on to where your foot is on this cord.
So many wires and crap.
Um,
coat.
Oh No,
I wanna yeah,
I don't think I'd do porn,
but I like sending dirty shit and I like getting it.
Well there you go.
That's what guys do all day long,
you know?
Well I think I do a joke about this,
but I told someone to send me a dirty video once and he sent me videos of him
fucking someone else coming on someone else.
But I felt bad because I didn't know if she knew.
So I watched it like twice and then deleted him.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I had to delete it,
but I want,
we had to watch him not long at all.
Like 30 seconds each or something.
The girl knows she's being recorded in it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Cause he,
when we had sex,
he tried to do stuff and I was like,
I don't trust you.
And now I'm glad I didn't send them.
And fascinated by,
um,
the,
uh,
the change in your dating guys.
How do you discover it?
How do you find out?
Basically I was in Australia,
I was in Melbourne for the comedy festival and meet this girl.
It's so good.
I want to go back so bad.
It's fun there.
Um,
but uh,
we had a mutual,
we have a mutual best friends,
so I knew I'd hang out with her.
And then we were at an art museum and I just looked over and I was like,
Oh my God,
I'm fucking in love with her.
And then I was like nervous,
but then I finally told her that I liked her.
And then you started and we made out and then we hooked up.
And then,
um,
I had to go to Sydney and she had to stay,
but we immediately started texting.
I'm a creep.
So Day two,
I was like,
can I buy tickets and see you?
And so we met up and then we just like would fly around and see each other.
Why then we would like,
you know,
text him.
Yeah.
Wow.
Was she a,
uh,
a native?
No,
she's in London.
She's in the new Netflix things that came out.
Oh Shit.
She knows.
No,
I talk about everything.
She actually asked me,
she's like,
can you please stop talking about me?
And she's like,
can you stop calling me a compulsive liar on podcasts?
I'm like,
I'll try it.
But it's hard.
So you guys are officially dating right now?
No,
I got Dom's Bro.
My heart was broken.
I was depressed for at six months and then last year I started therapy and
that's helped me a lot cause I was really,
truly sad.
Yeah.
I really loved her.
But now I'm like removed,
you know,
it's fine.
But we text sometimes.
What's your therapist saying about this?
Like,
well that a lot of my,
I think it was the first time I felt fully like loved and gave like,
I dunno,
I just,
it was a really good relationship while it lasted,
but she said most of my issues and why I can't let it go is because of other
stuff that I'd never explored and that she kind of gave me everything I've ever
wanted.
So.
Wow.
It's like more than that.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I never felt seen before.
Like a lot of comedians have that issue,
seen,
heard,
acknowledged,
all that stuff and it was hard.
I mean I would have married her but now I'm glad we're not together.
Oh yeah,
I would've,
yeah,
absolutely.
Because that would have been fine being long distance and everything,
but she couldn't do it up until you meet her at the festival.
Is it occurring to you that you might know?
Like I've had to,
I've had one group thing and I hooked up with a girl and I was like 21 in
Portland and then that was it.
But now,
yes.
Yeah.
I was staying at an anarchist.
We can pull out man.
I got stories.
Oh,
see my,
yeah,
Scottsdale was my Arizona time,
but um,
no,
I didn't know at all,
but I thought I liked having sex.
I just enjoyed having sex with her more than I've had with any dude.
That's great.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
Great to know.
No,
100%.
I'm just embarrassed because I'm so old,
you know?
I'm going to say you're very young.
I think that's for not knowing your kind of gay,
I don't know.
I feel so ignorant because my friends are like so gay.
It seems weird.
I didn't know.
But now everyone's like,
oh,
now you're like,
everyone will be easier for you.
The pool widen,
but I think it's like so specific now I want like a short haired girl dresses.
Kind of like a boy.
Oh boy.
Like girl,
what are you going to show?
[inaudible]
like let's say you,
you said,
hey,
will you send me?
Oh,
but I do want to tell you that she looks like all the boys I had crushes on as a
young girl.
Really that she looks like a boy.
Bander like she looks like Nick Carter,
like Leonardo Dicaprio.
He that always,
that's the part I don't understand about lesbian is it?
Yeah.
Okay,
so you like a woman but then she looks like the boy that he had.
So like it's why,
right?
So like what so confused.
It's fluid.
Jesus.
But she also fucks boys too.
We're all just,
yeah,
we're all just kind of,
what's your pronoun?
Wishy washy.
Do you have a pronoun?
No,
I'm fine.
That's what I always say.
This sounds bad,
but it's like,
I don't know if I can date a day.
That seems so complicated.
Like I wonder if they have a sense of humor.
I know,
but uh,
yeah.
What's Your Pronoun?
Um,
all right,
so here's a cool guy and I'm going to get graphic.
No,
it's super chill.
So just let me know.
Like what do you think of him?
Of like his whole appeal,
his style.
He's just like,
just check them out for a second.
Hi there guys.
It's Pete again and I'm here to do a little video and I wanted to use this but
by greeny toy that I bought this new one and I thought I'd try that again.
And then I also wanted to try this step one did fuck sleep.
He's used to it of course.
And then I went to look and they didn't send any batteries so
I'm not going to be able to use the vibrating
plate backwards,
so I'm sure that's going to get me off.
Yeah.
And it's kind,
it's got this cool builtin cockraine.
Oh and then I got this cool.
A friend of mine had mine.
Wait,
hold on.
Oh,
that's so cool.
I love him.
He's my favorite of the group,
isn't he great.
He's good.
He's got great energy,
great energy.
I liked that.
He is fun about the toys.
Yes.
So excited.
Yes,
and I liked that he went bad.
Bad because of the batteries.
Yeah.
He's a fun guy,
man.
You and I am one of the other guys.
Better than that.
You like the Benadryl and oldies.
I would take Benadryl or Joe over this guy.
Take Benadryl,
Benadryl.
Benadryl is severely,
severely unstable.
I know,
but that's why he won't harass.
You might,
she'll pass out what he,
this guy's pretty gay.
No,
this guy's definitely going to fuck you.
Then Benadryl guys going to pass out before anything.
I drill guys going to chop you up and put you in a box.
They'll be asleep before then.
No,
this guy's a maniac.
But at least you know the Benadryl guy would get caught.
He would not get away with murder.
He would not get away.
She would get caught.
But you'd be definitely dead.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I'll keep watching them
flexing with his boyfriend and it's a double ended dude.
So I really want to try this because I like fucking stuff at first.
I'm going to try and get this in my button and then this is the best product.
Little,
oh,
that was cool.
Control.
Nice texture to it.
Yeah,
go.
Doesn't like this part.
I love him.
I don't like the foot there.
Yeah.
And it's got a nice built in Cap rain,
which I thought was kind of cool.
It is kind of cool.
I just like that he's supporting his local porn store.
He totally is.
Yeah.
And he's,
and he's also,
you know,
it's like one of those review and people are like,
Hey,
have you seen the new BMW three series?
Here's all the features.
You know,
he's like one of those guys.
I love them.
Yeah.
Do we have more?
They're definitely more
my eye,
so it may take me a minute.
Oh Woo.
Get her.
Yeah.
I haven't had anything in my blood since my last,
uh,
but toy video,
someone's got to do it.
Yeah.
Someone's going to test these toys as a side.
I too,
like he's really put on a Hoodie.
Yeah.
Because she's so upset with this guy.
He's just so open with his sexuality.
That's what your boss is.
Not including anyone else in his,
you know,
he's not like,
come on to my dungeon.
Right,
right.
Going gonna make you feel good.
He was just like,
I'm going to have fun by myself and you're going to be going to,
you said abns.
Yeah.
Is that soon?
I'm going on the 20 lb there to the 23rd through the 27th and then Cardi B's
performing at the awards.
Bacardi Carta.
I love her.
My favorite thing is watching her eat shellfish.
She goes,
these are some good ass veneers.
They shit on Instagram.
It's like,
look at all this meat.
Like she's just luxury.
I love her.
She's fine.
She's like tapping on crab shells.
I just,
I really like her.
I'm really excited.
What are you going to be doing at Avn?
So people know for sure.
I'll be at the browsers booth.
Uh Huh.
Um,
and then I'll be at the red carpet at the award show and then I'm just going to
be a fan and a glitter dress watching the awards.
Wow.
And cheering from like,
I vote for them.
Like I vote for all the fan awards.
Yeah.
I treat it like I treat any other business.
I think that's what's like fucked as people don't respect these girls that are
just working.
Yeah.
No,
no,
I agree.
We agree.
That's why we celebrate,
uh,
the porno industry here because someone was telling me Riley Reid has over a
billion streams,
a billion,
which is like if she was a musician or a comment or anything,
it's like,
yeah,
she was on youtube.
She would make so much money.
It is a performance art thing too.
You know?
These are performers.
Yeah.
And people like Dick.
Hello?
Yeah.
Um,
what are your guys's categories?
I'm so vanilla.
I tell you what's not my categories.
It's weird because when you have a baby and you blow out your badge,
I think I've done that twice now.
It's really hard for me to watch porn,
like right after you have a baby because you're so medical,
like your body's still Kinda,
yeah.
So like,
I hate mealth stuff too.
I'm like,
oh,
that makes me cringe.
Mm hmm.
Trying to think I'm,
I'd say I'm kind of boring.
Sorry.
Regular regular one or two people to straight people or a few.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Suddenly so shy.
So I'm so,
but because I'm in so mom mode,
like I'm only like almost six months postpartum,
so I'm not like super sexual yet.
You know what I mean?
Your,
your body is still kind of cut that always weirds oh,
there's is a trend that I've found the uh,
when women squeeze their breast milk on people,
I'm not into,
I'm really,
I don't like it.
I like that.
I do like,
I do like the NBA is what?
It's homeless.
We,
I took her to a basketball game.
Oh this is really cool.
I would love to come back to watch these guys play basketball.
And I'm like,
are you being sarcastic?
Did you hate it?
No,
I loved it.
And then that night I dreamt that Tom had a big black dog did,
he was everything else was his color,
normal color and then huge black.
Everything else will buy normal color and size.
And then she was like,
but you have this big black cock right after the Laker game.
I mean,
come on.
I bought season tickets.
Yes.
Cool.
What's your genre?
I don't even know anymore.
I just like to see a grill kit dogged out,
you know,
just like wrapped around with like a lot of dudes
I like,
I mean I am pretty like I can watch,
you know how when you go to the tube sites,
um,
there's like a homepage.
I mean let's say there's 20 videos,
13 of them work for me.
I'm like,
I have my favorite set out.
Like I have to like figure out what I'm perfectly in the mood for.
I mean I'll tell you what else I discriminate.
I saw like there was like some BJ video.
Then there was like pass step.
Mom was like,
Hey,
oh me and your sister going to teach you how to fuck.
One of those was on my therapist said about the trauma and turning it
pleasurable.
Like there's a reason all this incest porn is so in,
it's just trauma.
It's like when the male,
yeah,
I think it's like a lot of people turning their creepy lives and to also look
little dicks.
It's humiliating.
I really don't like it.
I don't like it either.
For sure.
Whenever you [inaudible] whole ones,
it's like,
I dunno,
I want to see that.
I hate seeing an average size dick in a porn.
I'm serious.
I really am like,
come on,
like give us some fucking equipment to work with him.
I want to see something impressive.
And also actually like when the girl goes like cheese,
like how they can fit all of this and then they're like,
we're going to make it fit,
you know?
Yeah.
I can't get off on really on lesbian porn with a strap on now.
Even if I put my toy in and everything that feels extra fake to me.
Lesbian Porn,
really
my favorites.
Nikki hearts and her wife is hot and they're tatted up and they're gay.
And I like,
I liked the tatted up girls.
Yeah.
I like a Bella,
Donna.
She's neat.
She puts baseball bats and her,
but she's retired but an icon.
Yeah,
I like her.
She's nice as shit.
Yeah,
I met her once.
Yeah.
So,
um,
is there another cool guy or,
okay,
so please know about guide area.
No,
no,
please.
So listen,
we have this game.
Okay.
Um,
and we liked to play it.
I want to set it up correctly for you.
Do either of you watch bravo a ton?
This is like so much like Andy,
his clubhouse full.
Yeah.
With all the fun stuff.
Oh,
you got to keep adding.
We watch a million dollar fisting.
Okay.
Uh,
what's his name?
Jeff Lewis.
Although that show just got canceled,
which were in love with Jeff Lewis.
I'm so bomb the housewife shit though.
I don't want,
oh,
see,
I like the Vanderpump.
You guys would love Vanderpump.
I eat at a restaurant every now and then.
My shrink used to be right by their prompt.
They're such trash bags.
Yeah,
this is Tom.
What are you doing?
Oh yeah.
You know,
the scene in requiem for a dream.
And I was like,
it's so sad.
Like that is,
that turns me on.
Okay.
I loved that Alan's Oh,
okay.
Okay.
That end scene reverence.
Like it's so sad.
Like sometimes I'll pull it up.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Are traumatized.
I don't have my,
my,
uh,
intro for it,
but I do have,
so this is what we do is play these videos and we call the segment horrible,
are hilarious and we just basically want you to watch it and tell us whether you
think it's horrible or really funny.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's a wrestling video for people listening
tasting.
Oh,
all right.
Well I thought it was just going to be like a pussy juice hands
and I would've been fine with what happened for the listening audience is that
she pulled a,
a,
a tampon out that was very dark and appearance wiping me out.
What league,
what wrestling league as I said,
well that's a WWE.
No,
I don't know.
But those sounded like real fans of wrestling.
They did sound like it.
It looked like it was a fake tamp though.
Yeah,
I hope so.
I think so.
But again,
great performance.
Yeah,
the fans are great for us.
I don't know.
I was upset,
I think,
did we not explain why we didn't explain it very well to female wrestlers?
One pulled out a bloody tampon and put it in the other woman's mouth and said,
taste the tuna.
Now see,
we laugh about it,
but to be,
to be fair,
uh,
when we were actually watching it,
Christina was like this
and
yeah,
I don't think I laughed.
I definitely didn't laugh.
I didn't think you thought it was hilarious.
No.
Did you?
No,
no.
I don't think it was hilarious,
but as long as it's fake,
I'm okay with that.
Okay.
I just don't want it to be a real town.
Well,
I thought it was going to be the fish finger to watch the Osbornes.
Sharon Osborne would give the fish finger to her daughter.
The real was really funny.
Yeah,
she did it in the episode.
Osborne 10 years ago.
I'm going to give you the fish finger and then she put her hand down her coach
and her pants and then rub it.
The upper lip over daughter.
I'm giving you a fish.
It was cute.
I thought it was funny.
As motherly love.
I didn't think so.
Oh,
okay.
I have another one for you.
Okay.
I am liking the vibe of this.
Yeah,
me too.
Go ahead.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
okay.
Are you laughing?
I'm not laughing.
My husband's laughing.
Ooh.
Why didn't he try to take the cloth though?
He just kept enjoying.
I don't know.
I just don't get why you didn't try to save himself?
Yeah.
I don't know.
He really flipped out though.
It looked,
it looked scared.
Yeah.
I'm not into that.
I'm not interested.
I liked that.
That was pretty funny.
Okay.
Um,
but it was real,
right?
It wasn't acting.
Yeah.
I,
yeah.
I mean,
I didn't laugh,
so I guess it wasn't funny,
but,
oh,
I'm sorry.
Okay.
I get it.
Um,
I want to know what's next or do we talk [inaudible] you're not supposed to
laugh at that.
I think it was on a laugh at something.
Mental illness.
Don't laugh at that.
It wasn't mental illness.
He just had a crab on it.
You're your mental illness.
Oh,
laughing.
Go to shit.
This hurts.
People are hurting.
Yeah.
I don't like watching fights in movies.
Like if there's a fistfight,
I turn away really in a movie even.
Yeah.
Like in the movie kids a hundred,
if you remember that like too much.
I don't like physical fights or worldstar stuff like that.
Like people actually getting hurt and
bounces off of cement or something like that.
Yeah.
If I'm out and about and I see a fight,
I get really upset.
Like scared and upset.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
I'll call the cops.
Can I ask you,
what did you,
do you have any opinion?
I know you're from the Chicago area.
Yes.
Did you ever know anyone or,
or maybe you yourself became a fan of Garth Brooks?
No.
No,
but I know Garth Brooks fans.
Is it and how do you know them?
Um,
there are everywhere.
I mean he is very popular.
Very Fair.
He's really popular.
You a little astounded by it.
By the level of notoriety and fame.
Yes.
It's pretty significant.
Maybe it'd be if we saw him alive,
we would understand.
I've heard that argument a lot.
Tried a man.
I'm watching the concert on cvs and like it's just hokey.
He's kind of a Corny Dad.
Boehner.
Like,
at one point he was doing like the heart hand,
like I live,
he goes like,
Nah.
Um,
there are cooler than just playing country,
but I saw the Dixie chicks a couple of years ago.
They were great.
I got too hammered,
but I cried so much and I just loved them.
You know,
some people that are buying a Bandana,
if you really Dixie chicks,
Bam,
Bam.
There's some people who think that,
you know,
Garth may have bodies head and on his ranch and that he pretends to be human and
that it's all just a big act.
Um,
this is footage from his most recent CBS concert.
You were talking about somebody,
this is the one I almost pretending to be human.
Go ahead.
And,
um,
everybody,
Garth Brooks here in iconic Notre Dame locker room,
this is where the players go out to take the field every Saturday.
This is where all our players are getting ready to take the field for this
concert.
So tonight the fighting Irish,
they're going to become the singing Irish.
This is going to be good.
That was like real just dad boundary.
Yeah,
I had manufactured.
Yeah.
I just feel it when you're famous for that long,
you become semi just mentally fucked.
Yeah.
I don't think you can stay normal being famous for decades.
Especially that famous.
Yeah.
It's just impossible.
That's why they all are nuts.
I can't that because everyone is fake to you.
Everybody.
No one is real.
Everyone wants something from you or treats you too nice and no one tells you
you're wrong and I,
and you can't go anywhere.
And I think it just makes you absolutely insane.
I think you're right.
I think you're totally right.
And I think,
you know,
maybe he's handling it well as compared to like a Michael Jackson.
Yeah.
Will legally it it just fucked.
Or like when people act mad about everything Madonna does.
It's like,
yes,
she's been famous since the 80s it's bound to make you not a real shot of her
side.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She's always posting or do you follow her on the gram?
Yeah.
Well,
no,
I,
I'm addicted to Instagram,
so I bake.
I just recently unfollowed like thousands and thousands of people.
Oh No.
It has to be only people like soak.
I don't know.
I just can't.
So now it's like you're all caught up and I have nothing to look at,
but then I just go to the explore page.
I mean,
I just love,
I love it too.
I'm fascinated,
but I follow her and she's adopted about,
I don't know,
12 African children at this point,
and the only thing she plays is have them singing and dancing.
Like she makes them sing and dance constantly.
It's like,
oh,
this looks terrible.
Like having Madonna's your adopted mom.
Like you think it's fun.
It's just terrible.
Yeah.
Come on,
dance.
Let's see what else he's got.
Don't miss it.
Legendary coach blue hopes had the sign put up.
That's now probably one of the most famous sides if football history.
Well,
they ripped it.
No.
Oh yeah,
you're right.
It's,
it looks like a high,
super compressed.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Now Lou Holtz,
Lou Holtz
actually guy,
and he was on one of those horrible football shows you watched where he would be
at the round table telling the bad dad
this mush mouth is on television.
Great.
And they're paying him like millions,
millions.
Meanwhile,
they can't let a woman over 60 be on television.
Yeah,
it's true.
Yeah.
She's always pointing it out.
Something I had never noticed before,
but I'm like,
oh,
you're totally right.
It's like a guy can be a fucking dog,
a fucking basset hound,
and he gets prime time television spots,
but like that a woman,
they'd be like,
get Outta here with that fucking face.
Super Hot woman.
And they'll still tell you that you're disgusting.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's true.
I have that.
But that part that you can be on your a game.
I mean,
people call Rihanna fat,
you know,
it's just,
she's perfect.
She is perfect.
Her and Miley or like my,
Oh,
Miley's hottest for me.
Yeah.
Miley and Rhiana.
Your celebrity crush your celeb crush?
I think so.
I think anybody would go gay for Rihanna.
You'd have to.
She's so pretty.
She's very patient.
She's wild.
I heard she made Leonardo Dicaprio lose weight before she fucked him.
She's like,
you're fat.
And got him a trainer and he had to lose weight.
The fucker.
Who knows if it's real.
I don't know.
Straight Savitri man and she was like,
that was that waistline.
She's so cool.
I'll eat the booty though either.
But no,
I wouldn't need anybody.
I don't want to eat but I'm not
in kindergarten.
Well my prediction is eating ass is slowly on the decline and pissing is going
to go up in popularity.
Tell us about water.
Sports are going to be more in,
I think people are going to be more confident to talk about their p fetishes.
I just think people will be in,
this is just on a limb.
This is coming from,
no,
I'm actual sources but I think cause squirting has been so in recently that I
think it's just like such a stopover to the pill.
What do you think of those people that say that squirting is actually paying?
Some of it is,
yeah,
I believe scored is piss.
I don't think it's something that's 100% pissed,
but I think it's maybe 40% fluid be.
If it's not all pissed.
I'm not sure.
Magic magic magic.
I don't know what it is,
but I know the girls in porn drink pedialyte and Gatorade frost and they're
peeing and they're hydrating and pissing.
That's not fully square.
But um,
yeah,
cause it's not yellow.
No,
it's not yellow so it can't be all p.
Hmm.
They're well hydrated though.
They are,
but as to me as great,
I don't want it.
I don't want to in Tom's been trying to get me to lick a scrum for a decade and
it's just not going to happen.
Which would you let someone else look as but I mean,
no,
we're married.
We're not open.
Even if you were in the room,
no,
I wouldn't be comfortable with it.
Like a nice,
maybe you should just get a fake tongue and today want to feel the spread.
You wouldn't let someone do that?
No.
Would you let someone like my scrum if I wasn't willing to do it.
Now you're opening up a whole thing.
That was our opening up a whole thing.
If there's stuff you won't do,
your someone else can do it.
Right.
What you're saying is that you don't want to do it.
Would you hire?
Would you let someone else do it and then you're like,
would you let someone do it to me,
but I'm willing to do it.
See,
that's the difference.
If we find something that you won't do,
am I allowed to have someone else do it?
Such as staple my tits.
The desk we've been talking about that for,
but you don't really want that.
I just
promise you're to open.
Yeah,
you're too willing to willing to get that toy.
That's like us.
A spinny thing of tongues.
And then I'll just,
there you go.
And what?
She can spread your butt cheeks.
He'll hold the tongue machine.
Or even if Terry,
if you got him to come over with his toys,
we got,
Terry helped me put the plug in.
Can I,
can you help me out?
Put your foot up on the table.
Like Lisa likes.
I look levelheaded so we could both Terry and I can look at each other when the
girls are like doing the,
when they're on the floor,
but then their legs are fully,
oh,
it's just the guy standing on top of the pile driver.
Oh Man.
I hear wedding bells whenever I say I love that.
I want to see photos from her wedding.
Oh,
it's really nice.
You're just looking at them.
Last night you mentioned
I'm going to be a bridesmaid and I was a bridesmaid and my sister's wedding at
like age 12 but my,
one of my best friends asked me this week and I'm doing the speech at the
wedding.
Yeah.
I'm excited to tell the wedding crime.
You're going to AVN from there.
They all know.
They know the wedding's in December,
but this is like my best friend.
Her mom knows me.
They all know.
They all know I like porn.
Good.
But I also,
I think the reason it's damaging to do does they don't realize it's like a job
and the girls are acting and doing stuff and then they take the moves home with
them and it fucks with their brains and what sex is supposed to be like.
But I think I'm aware enough that hopefully fuck my brains.
Entertainment.
Yeah.
And it's to turn you on.
I just hope I,
I hope it doesn't mess me up in my brain.
Oh is that your concern was watching porn?
Yeah.
How much are you watching?
I actually haven't watched since I've been here,
so like for a week?
Yeah,
I guess I'm okay right now.
Yeah.
But at home I'll just be,
I'll be late to stuff for sure.
Yeah.
Like I should get in the shower and I'm like,
well I should,
I should watch porn before I get in the shower.
Right.
I was late to the school,
our brothers one time I was watching porn.
Where's there an any situation?
Cause I don't,
I'm not interested in ass ever.
And people always tell me what if someone's showers completely and you see that
and I'm like,
I still don't want to tell you why.
I mean real talk.
I love taking shits.
I love,
I like Browning and I,
to me it's not sexual and I don't want a dick or a finger or anything in there.
It's not hygienic man.
There's Poopoo in there.
Yeah,
Google comes out.
It smells bad.
A couple of Nice lips look couple miles back there.
Just eating up some lunch.
Have you always wanted this?
No,
of course.
It's never going to have be my scrub master.
No,
he's his bottles.
Harry.
He's here.
You'd have to get it.
Whitey.
Yeah,
he's nasty.
You know it's a hot bag.
They're even touched a guy's butthole.
Yeah.
I actually,
one of my,
yeah,
I have,
I've been in there.
It's not nice.
It's like it hot and steamy and Harry will cause then you don't want to do
anything else with your hand of course.
And you have to like,
you're just thinking about it too much.
It's a surprise digit in there from a real SLU tea.
And then I returned the favor and there was a lot of chocolate.
Yes.
What slow is this?
Went.
Oh,
you're African slash.
No.
Well that's uh,
yeah,
the porn stars.
I watched this interview thing and it's like,
what's your most embarrassing moment on set?
And they've all shat in someone like everyone.
I believe that that's where like if you're going to play,
yeah,
you're gonna,
you're going to encounter it.
And then the other crazy thing,
if they work on their periods,
they put makeup sponges in there,
pussy and then sometimes they forget about it.
And that's the other thing that people talk about.
It's like you'll just get a girl at onset and they smell so bad and it's because
they forgot their makeup sponge up their makeups now away from us.
I was like,
just put like sponge,
like there's an actual menstrual sponge you can put up there or it's a form of
birth control.
I feel.
I bought a cup and it was very difficult.
I did not work for me.
Imagine like being,
it was not good.
Too much work.
It was,
it was a problem for sure.
But that's the thing was also being with a girl.
No,
the periods that are the ones really that grossed out,
which is helpful way,
but then when you're both on your ladies,
we were,
we'd had,
that never happened.
Oh,
but you don't,
you go downstairs,
you go downtown when she's on her.
I didn't,
but she,
there was just like blood all over our hands,
but no one really cared.
It was kind of an invigorating,
I dunno,
I liked it.
I am so square.
Apparently I'm the man.
Well,
but you're getting it in more often.
Like,
I'm pretty sexual I guess in a creep.
But I don't,
I,
I not enough people want to have sex with me.
So it's a problem.
No,
I'm telling like I haven't had sex in a year.
I fucked this weird couple in Scottsdale exactly a year ago.
That's correct.
Yeah.
We were just talking about how Arizona is so weird for that kind of stuff.
Swingers.
Yeah,
they don't do anything.
It's hot.
They have nowhere to go.
And then the houses are cheap so they have enough room to do what they want.
And you so he had sex with a married couple or just start Tinder?
Well,
cause I didn't know if I was gay or not what I was going to do and I hadn't,
I was like,
I hadn't hooked up since I got dumped.
So I was like I'll fuck a couple.
And so I found them on Tinder and there was a hotter couple that I met,
but I did it.
A couple on Tinder or are you just looking for one person?
Like,
usually if you,
if you look for girls on dating apps,
it's,
there's so many couples to the point where lesbians were not interested in
threesomes.
I don't want to fuck your boyfriend.
So a lot of couples will go on as just the girl.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they had tattoos and stuff.
So I chose them.
I feel like Phoenix is the city where over the last 10 years has to be four or
five times where people like a couple have been like,
do you want to hang out tonight?
And I'm like,
don't want to hang out tonight.
And
Phoenix always.
I feel like it's in the water there.
Yeah.
There's a lot of partiers out there.
It attracts a certain party girl or a party guy shows in Scottsdale.
Guy came up to me after my sentence that just so you know,
she squirts all over me all the time.
Thanks.
Yeah,
it's cool.
no there.
I felt more connected to this couple,
but then it wasn't a good thing.
They had like neon blue lights around the bed.
Oh God.
It was bad.
That's terrible.
But I stayed and I,
he was racist.
I think that's right up your alley.
Yeah.
Perfect.
No,
he was gross.
She was pretty fun.
See that?
Yeah.
I just have to find a girlfriend.
Not so sure.
There are people that will like fuck me,
but like I want,
you know,
I want to like the person of course course.
But um,
I can't,
he was just nasty looking dude.
He just,
it was more about him and he kept trying to be bossy and it wasn't about
everyone's it,
he was just like to me,
me,
me and bothered me.
And it seemed like she was trying to like please him verse herself.
I just didn't like the dynamics of,
and then in the more,
not in the morning,
I didn't stay overnight,
but afterwards I was waiting for my car and he told his wife,
he goes,
Hey,
don't forget to ask you.
I ice your pussy so it doesn't hurt in the morning.
Which means,
which meant that he said that regularly.
Tell you
yes.
It's like they're just fucking for pay.
I don't know.
It just was weird.
I got to tell you,
if you're in a married relationship and you have family and a mortgage and all
that,
it just seems crazy.
Doesn't it seem crazy to you?
It was normal to me
to be like,
yeah,
let's just meet the strange nice lady on an app and then hover over and the
party man as a crazy alive,
so it's a party and it was funny.
They were telling me how all of his family like hates her and the whole time I
was like,
yeah,
I get what's happening here.
Of course.
Are The black shirts of the family,
was there an age gap between them?
You know,
but she was from Iowa.
She was just,
you seem very like,
you're like,
it's,
that's what I did.
Did,
did you have threesomes before?
I had one for some of my life before that and they were in the front row at
Caroline's.
Wow.
They took me,
they basically after the set we talked and then we had a drain.
It was two guys and a girl and I've been telling this story for so long.
I'm so boring.
Like,
I need a new sex story.
But,
um,
I thought the guy was hot and so I waited for them and then we chit chatted and
then after her to drink,
they were like,
listen,
we're actually not a couple.
We're all here to fuck each other.
We have a hotel room,
there's coke,
Molly,
we'd love for you to come.
Wow.
And I said,
absolutely.
And do you do do,
you'd have to do the drugs?
I don't like cocaine,
but I did Molly.
I love Molly was a crazy experience.
It was awesome.
It was like all my dreams came true.
It really was like a fantasy fulfilled.
It was fine.
Yeah.
I liked it.
And they were,
they were good people that are like a drawer full of toy,
you know?
They were like prepared.
This is their hobby and something like that.
How long do you stay?
You know what I mean?
Like,
oh,
I went straight to my babysitting job in the morning from,
yeah,
I'm glad you guys have a gnarly,
did you shower him before?
No.
And I didn't think I was going to have a wild night,
so I don't even have my phone charger or anything and I just showed up in black
heeled boots and like a black dress with lace sleeves at eight 15 in the
morning.
So the upper east side where they cool.
No,
the mom knew something was wrong with the mom knew I was a backup nanny,
so I worked for an agency for years,
so I just showed up and did like last minute care.
She knows she went to where,
I mean it is wild that people,
maybe they trust the agency,
but the amount of,
even tiny babies I would show up and they'd be like,
notes are on the table by,
and I'm like,
all right.
It is weird.
I mean I was very good at my job and I care about children,
but it is really crazy that they just trusted a 20 something girl.
I would usually show up in sweatpants and they would just leave me with their
three months old.
It's for days.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm not down with that shit at all.
No,
it's weird.
It's fucking know who watches your kid,
you have your anatomy but then do your parents or something or you have a
babysitter?
We have no parents involved.
Just like,
yeah,
a couple people that we trust.
Okay.
Like our lady's been with us since Ellis was four months old.
He's three now.
Like we were very,
no way,
dude.
No fucking way.
No,
it was weird because I would come from partying all the time.
I can't believe I've babysat probably over a hundred families and um,
my butt back to this person.
Oh yeah.
I gotta ask you because I always wonder because I'm so uptight.
Like,
I mean I be,
what don't you like so be in your head like,
oh,
I'm so fat.
I'm fatter than anybody here.
And like,
well yeah,
it wasn't shaved her,
I wasn't for a wild night.
Well we were on Molly,
so I just feel like you kind of feel great.
But they also were,
cause we would take breaks or chill or two people.
We had watched,
it was like an all night kind of extravaganza.
So while we like chatted,
they were like really impressed with like,
we can't believe it's your first time,
you're really in it.
And I'm like,
thank you.
So I felt good.
Yeah,
they were in town,
the other one's wife was coming and they were all going to go to some sex party.
Like this is their hobby because people always ask,
they're like,
where their condoms?
I'm like,
yes,
this is what they do.
They're not,
they're not going to fuck with.
And they all,
here's the thing though.
A lot of times you watch these shows like real sex and stuff.
Yeah.
We're like,
you know these documentaries and like there's some real dogs doing this.
Are they trying to,
the guy was not hot,
but the other guy was really high and the girl was really queue.
But neither of their dicks for like giant or anything.
But they had tons of dildos.
Right.
So they didn't care.
Yeah.
More than enough.
But yeah,
maybe it's a dude.
I got real sex was weird for sure cause that's how I got my sex education was
real sex and Howard stern at midnight after SNL I'd put it on and I remember
that real sex show.
You're right.
It was always like we're into group masturbation and it was like the most
unattractive people in the world that you would never want to be naked.
So many glass dildo episodes.
There was just always making glass dildos at factories.
Like how many fucking pony tails we're going to see.
My friend just recently got a new pony and he's like,
I think people are treating me different and like they sure are.
They sure are.
I'm like,
you're basically like,
hey dude.
He's like,
it's not fair.
I'm like,
no,
but you can cut it off.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah.
People are not going to be nice to know what's happening.
Shoveled.
You're unlikeable and you're pushy.
I was just trying to make a point about how people talk about women.
I just,
I dunno.
I thought you were great on that.
I had so much fun,
but I think people are,
people are like,
you don't know about politics.
I'm like,
you,
we don't know shit.
It's whatever.
Like anybody who comments on anything,
there's going to be people that say that on,
you know what I mean?
Like you could say that about football.
You could say it about,
uh,
hunting.
You can say it about politics.
Like if you make a comment.
Yeah.
And it's a on a popular platform.
I guess that's what it is to where I've never usually,
no one cares what I say.
So I guess I was shocked that People Watch,
you're getting the experience of a lot of people paying attention to it.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
And then best thing to do is to do what you did and not engage it.
At first it was like all these fun gifts and I was like,
this is fun.
I love the new,
I don't know.
I doubt it's new,
but I like when people say like,
I see no lies.
I like that.
I got a lot of this.
Yeah.
Well,
I think are in the era of,
um,
you know,
nobody,
you,
you don't have to be an expert in anything anymore,
just have an opinion,
which is kind of great and kind of not great simultaneously,
you know,
cause you don't get the,
if you do make a comment and you're not an expert,
people shit on you.
However,
because of the Internet,
it's like the democratization of information and he ever,
anybody can read anything and figure shit out and I don't think we're actually
reading anything.
I think,
I know for me it's just headlines,
Twitter and what my top friends tell me.
Yeah.
That's why when people were like,
you don't have a grasp on modern politics.
I'm like,
I'm sure you're right,
but I don't think you have more than me.
Right.
I just don't buy that.
They're smarter than me.
And you're a comedian.
Your job is to be funny and entertaining and you did that.
Yeah.
They're just evil.
I don't know what their goal is.
Go to work.
Like I just don't understand what you're doing.
You're tagging every single black person that follows me.
Yeah.
It's like insane.
A lot of time it's not so crazy this direction.
I wonder if they all know each other.
No,
probably now.
And they're like,
if you were this progressive person that loves Bernie,
why are you shutting people down?
Dude?
It's,
it's not indicative.
I think look like social media isn't even reality,
you know?
Yeah.
Really you can get lost in it.
That's the danger.
You can get lost in it and you can start to think that this is the world and
then you realize if you do what you did like jump off for a couple of days,
you realize like that's not the world.
Yeah,
I was,
I was going down some crazy rabbit hole that I can get so involved in that.
I think it's everything and it's,
it's not a really a reflection of the real world.
No.
So not at all.
Um,
then we are to be off of my phone.
Yeah.
It was probably healthy though for you.
No,
I was listening to this.
I think it was actually Dr Drew's podcast about habits.
Anyway,
this person was saying when they could write and they were sitting down to
write,
they would leave their phone in another room in the house.
And that way they weren't tempted to compulsively look at the phone cause it's a
compulsion at this point.
Most of read that it's like,
um,
it's having a slot machine in your pocket because not every time you get
dopamine,
but you know it's coming soon with any like,
or message or text.
Yeah.
So you just keep checking it for the hope that someone's giving you attention.
Right.
I know.
I wish I can get a land line and just have an answering machine and live that
life.
I want to go back.
You can't sell bad.
Yeah,
we'll see.
I Dunno,
I'm real,
because when I,
I've,
I have been leaving my phone at home if I just,
I'm leaving the house for a few hours.
Right.
But the whole time I'm like,
I'm reaching for it constantly.
Or I'm about to,
Oh,
I should message this person.
I should take a photo.
Oh,
I should,
you know,
it's the story that it is weird.
Even without it.
I'm just thinking about it all the time.
You know,
Arusha fear is like big on that.
Yes.
He has a flip phone,
he has a flip phone,
which has totally psychotic,
but he's always encouraging us,
um,
to like take social media off our phones and all that stuff.
And you know,
sometimes I,
he'll hit me with the right message on the right day about it and I'll,
I'll just like not look that day and I do feel better.
Yeah.
You get more done.
I mean,
that's what I was reading too.
It's like our memories and experiences are going to be looking at our phone
because we're,
it's hard for our brains to multitask.
So all the new experiences that we're having in our brains,
remembering his phone related,
like we're not creating new memories with the world around us.
Right.
It's wild.
Yeah.
But we're addicted.
We're totally addictive.
But I bought a planner and an alarm clock,
but I keep just on my phone.
I can't,
I don't know.
Hmm.
Oh,
never.
No,
it's dwindling down.
Let me ask you a road stuff or you have anything coming up?
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to be in Vancouver for JFL fantastic city.
One of my favorite cities.
I don't know where I'm going to be.
Honestly.
I'm glitter cheese that are all of you.
I don't know where I'm going to be.
Well I know you're going to be in Fort Worth,
Texas I think in March.
Okay.
And that's it.
And she'll be at the brazzers booth.
Yeah.
Browsers.
I bought a really slutty outfit.
Oh yeah,
the Internet.
Do you shop on [inaudible]?
No,
I've seen it.
Yeah.
No I don't.
It's so good.
Okay.
We have to do is just get a quick update.
Um,
so as you know,
the studio is still under construction.
There's still soundproofing.
Um,
we actually had to shut down soundproofing because other businesses in this
business park where like what the fuck is going on over there?
Cause it was so loud and that has delayed a couple of things.
Right.
So what,
what's up with the other shows coming to the,
to our channel.
So right now the tentative schedule is for the other shows to be starting around
February,
like February 1st week of February,
first week,
second week of February.
We'll start staggering them out.
So you know,
we'll start off with either Dr Drew's show Sickler Santina.
Okay.
Um,
and also San now since he's recording in his other studio,
we'll start posting some of those videos that he's recording the different
location until he starts here.
Okay.
So we'll put like his videos on our channel.
Yes.
Okay,
great.
Coming in February.
[inaudible] is such a cool married couple.
Thanks.
You're really doing it.
Yeah,
I love her.
Are you guys going to write a book or what?
I know we've made babies advice.
We made two children already.
Yeah.
Advice.
I don't know for advice.
I don't think so.
Well it seems like you're happy and honest with each other.
I don't know.
I think this podcast is our,
uh,
our gift to the world,
right?
Yeah.
Kind of total.
Totally like ourselves.
Can I tell you what it is?
It's the best actually advisor,
whatever is as a married couple is find something you enjoy doing together.
Like this is kind of what he and I do together that we did before we had
children.
So kind of reminds us of a time of total silliness.
Total lack of responsibility.
We were just to,
Dick had comedians who started a show.
So yeah,
if you find something you enjoy doing outside of like children and career or
whatever,
if you can't,
I mean,
even though this is our job,
but yeah,
that helps.
That's huge.
Like a hobby together.
Something you can do together.
Uh,
any tennis.
What else do you guys do?
Do you guys do nights?
Yes.
We have date night,
Karen this week.
Thursday.
Yup.
Yes.
You start to schedule it more when you have babies.
You're like,
we will have dinner on Thursday.
No,
having babies seems insane.
It's,
it's,
yeah.
Having more than one baby's insane.
Dude.
I just remembered something.
I was like,
have you got any date?
We're doing some gigs together.
Yeah.
I'm opening for you in Boston.
Oh,
there you go.
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
She's super funds that people know those Boston shows.
Is it April or May?
One of the April or May.
We're actually,
that's exciting.
So go see Lee's opened for Tommy Bunch.
Louder.
Yes.
We are getting from this.
I'm telling you.
I'll tell you right now,
it's uh,
it's April.
You're right.
We're actually starting in Bethlehem,
pa.
Oh,
cool.
On the sands casino.
And then we're doing Medford,
which is just outside of Boston,
like 15 minutes.
Then we do proper Boston and then we'd go back to Medford.
Wow.
So we're going back and forth.
Uh,
but we're gonna end up doing one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Wow,
that's so wild.
I'll see her.
Sealys a trigger on a,
the degenerates.
What number are you on?
That one?
I forget.
Number four.
Check her out.
She's number four.
Did you guys already talk about how the door almost fallen you?
Yeah,
lot.
Countless Times.
What a nightmare.
What a fucking shit show.
I can't believe it.
How am I,
how many weeks or days later did you give birth?
Oh,
about six weeks later.
Okay.
So,
yeah,
that was like the last thing I did and I just sat in my pool for the rest of the
summer.
I have a special kind of brag thing.
I know you're trying to end this,
but I have friends here and I was with them the day she found out she was
pregnant with her second baby and then wildly I was in town and I was going to
her house and I was there the day her water broke.
So the day,
yeah,
I felt really special and cool.
And I met the baby yesterday or two days ago,
so she don't go,
go.
Um,
she's good.
I don't know,
it's her,
it was an unplanned thing.
So their babies one and a half and now they have a two month old.
So it's really an it say goodbye to her for her because the baby doesn't even
understand why anything.
It's like they have two babies.
That's crazy town.
That's a crazy short age gap.
Yeah.
But if you're just saying you're going to get pregnant.
That's right.
Do you watch,
um,
uh,
what's it called?
You know,
I was pregnant.
Teen moms know love after lock lock going.
Yeah,
no love after a lockup is fucking amazing.
And that's on,
what is it?
We TV or something,
something like that.
It's on iTunes and it's people that meet people on the inside,
you know,
like they do the pen pal thing.
Uh,
there's sites for like,
Hey,
do you want to meet a felon?
I guess.
And they start these romances and then it continues,
you know,
the,
the camera crew joins as a person is released.
It's a basically a formula for disaster every time.
But there's couple
where this is like my favorite,
the guy and the girl had a baby like three months before he went to prison.
He's getting out of prison.
He now likes another girl,
not the,
the baby's mother.
And he's like,
I'm going to have,
I have to have sex with her,
keep her chill.
And then she's like,
we're not going to use,
you don't have protection.
But it's like,
I dunno,
we'll see.
We'll just see what happens.
And then like,
but she's also realizes that he's totally unstable and not,
you know,
yeah.
But she's thinking if I could lock him down with two babies,
he's not gonna leave me one baby.
Someone can walk.
But she's thinking like two babies.
Yeah.
That's what I do with you.
I know you guys,
Svu fans are now linode RSV,
but I feel like he should be cause he loves crime and killing so much.
I love Mariska.
Hargitay yeah,
there's just good detectives.
Benson unstable or there's just great.
But there was one episode with John Stamos and he was a reproductive rapist.
Oh,
where do you would have consensual sex with women,
but poke holes in condoms.
And so we had dozens of babies everywhere and he just kept wanting to make more
and more babies.
Oh,
that's nasty.
Yeah.
But John Stamos is one of the only people I've seen in person that I got giddy
and like lost my breath.
Like he is really handsome,
handsome.
I never ages,
I couldn't even get my words together.
I've never felt that way before.
But he really is hot.
Yes.
John Stamos.
That Dude's genetically gifted though.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's gotta be like fucking 58 or something like that.
All that yogurt,
Goddamn fucking,
hey man,
you know,
got married that list last week.
Megan trainor and the boy from spykids.
Oh,
I don't know.
Oop.
Exactly.
Okay.
All about that bass about that,
you know that songs she got married at,
but one of my favorite tha the,
I became obsessed with them because there a photo of them leaving a sex store
with like a bag of dildos.
Yes.
And they got married last week and I've been stalking them on Instagram.
It's either we do that in Toronto.
We bought sex toys on the road in Toronto.
Is it Toronto?
[inaudible]
hmm.
Did we bring them to the show?
I don't remember what,
what the fuck maybe.
Hmm.
Anyway,
that was part again.
Yup.
Um,
I want to thank,
um,
the great people at Saatva.
All our sponsors obviously are huge corporate sponsor,
loving it.
Donald's for all the money.
Well,
I told Christina,
but I recently had an antique store,
found an old happy meal toy of a mic nugget,
which whoa.
And I have it.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
Wow.
I wonder if we'll have access now to like old library of toys and you know,
and stuff from our connection to them.
Yeah.
I hope PSI.
The hamburglar toy or something.
This is for my son.
We got this in the happy meal to truck.
Fantastic.
No,
we don't gender him
Mcdonald's.
Yeah,
let's talk about that.
But yeah.
Yeah.
They were like thought a boy's toy or whatever.
Or they said it was a boy's toy.
Right.
Base declared like it's a boy's toy and we're like,
we'll decide what's a boy's toy.
Um,
you know,
I'm not gonna let somebody tell me just because someone tells me it's my son.
That's my son.
You know what I mean?
Let him decide.
He's three.
He knows that by now.
He knows what gender he is.
Yeah.
I mean they fuck,
there you go again,
Tom.
It's child abuse.
You changed our younger son's diaper today.
Did you ask consent?
No,
I just changed it.
That's something you're supposed to do.
Did you do that when you were babysitting?
No.
Oh,
did you guys watch the circumcision documentary?
Why are you anti circumcision?
I just honestly,
I didn't have an opinion going into it.
Yeah.
But everyone on every side is a lunatic and they get crazier and crazier as the
movie goes on.
You kind of end up hating everybody.
Yeah.
But,
um,
I guess I'm,
I guess I don't get,
I don't care,
but I don't get why people are so into it.
Yeah.
I mean the people who are really anti circumcision kind of,
I dunno,
they kind of amused me.
Yeah.
When they're like,
how you
dare you figure these bodies.
Yeah.
What,
the people that are so into circumcision or even crazier.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've,
I guess I've never heard of watch this documentary.
It's a lunatics after lunatics the whole way through.
Wows me out.
I'll check it out.
Sorry.
I brought it up.
Um,
all right.
So Lisa Trager glitter cheese.
Go see her on the road.
Go see her at Avn.
Comes here with me.
Well,
I try and degenerate.
She's watched her for Elisa.
Triggers your name.
Yup.
Flicks.
Um,
Christine is going to be a next in Denver,
Denver,
Colorado at the comedy versus downtown is one is down to January 31st through
February 2nd.
Those condos are so good.
Yeah,
I'm stuck.
But tickets are almost gone a lot.
Those are almost gotten so by them.
The last thing that I have tickets available for this month is,
but the third show in Dallas at the majestic,
that's on Sunday,
January I believe.
27th.
So,
uh,
there's a few tickets left if you want to grab them.
Otherwise,
pick up,
uh,
the tour again in the long beach in February.
Um,
I think that's it for us.
My fucking cut.
Oh,
okay.
And this song is a full throttle.
The ballot of Joe and Julia by the t c are,
thanks so much.
We'll see you next week guys.
No.
Okay.